So, heute Pfeiffer-Time, Leute.
Broggers, ja.
Wir benchmarken heute mal ein paar Sachen.
Und zwar, ich glaube, ich zeige euch das.
Bevor ich jetzt lange erzähle, ich zeige euch das einfach.
Also, wir haben ja auch im Stream schon ein bisschen mit Web...
Ich muss mal ein bisschen leiser machen.
Heute schon gesportet, ja, heute Morgen.
Und, allerdings, die Lautstärke kann zwar wieder nicht entscheiden.
Okay.
Aber heute nur 5,56 Kilometer.
Nicht wieder 10 plus wie letzten Sonntag.
Also, ganz normale Runde, die ich sonst auch renne.
Die, naja, wobei nicht exakt die gleiche.
Meine normale Runde 6,2.
Ich mach schon mal meine VM an.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal, bevor es losgeht, ich zeige euch jetzt, was wir machen.
Und, dann futter ich nochmal zwei Plätzchen, die ich mitgebracht habe, hier gerade.
Aber in der Zwischenzeit können wir nochmal Package-Update auf der VM machen,
falls es es in der Zwischenzeit schon gegeben hat.
Weil, ich glaube, zuletzt haben wir heute Morgen geupdatet.
Also, ich zeige euch, was wir heute machen.
Ich glaube, das wird recht spannend.
Zumindest interessieren mich die Ergebnisse auch.
Und zwar, wir rufen heute von C-Sharp aus,
sowohl Rusty, als auch von C-Sharp, aus.
Sowohl Rusty, als auch von C-Sharp, aus.
Sowohl Rust Funktionen auf, als auch Go-Funktionen.
Das liegt daran, ihr könnt euch vielleicht noch dran erinnern,
ich hab im Stream ja schon öfters mal ein bisschen mit WebRTC auf Serverseite rumgebastelt.
Zum Beispiel, dass man sich connecten kann in einem Browser und dann Webcams abspielen und solche Geschichten.
Also, ich hab ja schon öfters mal ein bisschen mit WebRTC rumgebastelt.
Und ich hab die letzten Tage über mal so ein bisschen Just for Fun wieder ein bisschen rumgebaut mit WebRTC.
Also, WebRTC ist quasi...
Realtime Video im Browser
Nicht Streaming, wohlgemerkt, nicht Streaming
Sondern, also Streaming
Ist ja meistens HLS
Also HLS ist
Was heißt das?
Für was steht HLS eigentlich?
Gute Frage
HTTP Live Streaming, okay
Wusste ich gar nicht
Also die ganzen Streaming Seiten
Die funktionieren meistens über HLS
HLS ist relativ easy, HLS gibt es
Eine
M3U8 Datei
Und da stehen dann URLs drin
Die rotated werden und alle paar
Sekunden gibt es da
Einen neuen Eintrag drin und dann
Streamt das, also das macht ab und zu mal ein Get
Und dann holt sich so ein 5 Sekunden Häppchen vom Stream
Und dann macht es wieder ein Get
Neues 5 Sekunden Häppchen
WebRTC ist tatsächlich Realtime
Von Endgerät zu Endgerät
Das ist besonders gut, wenn man
Möglichst Latency Free Video haben will
Was cool ist für
Ja Audio Calls
Also beispielsweise Microsoft Teams
Und sowas, das läuft nach Möglichkeiten über WebRTC
Und halt auch
Für Videokameras
Wenn man zum Beispiel drauf gucken will, wer vor der Tür steht
Und sowas
Und das möglichst Latency Free sehen will
Alles, dann ist WebRTC gut
Aber das machen wir heute nicht, ich sag nur
Wie ich drauf gekommen bin
Und ich verwende für
Oh ich hab irgendwas im Auge, das ist ja super
Abartig ey
Razer, danke für den Sub
Und by the way, wir installieren gerade mal
Die neue
Die neue Jetbrains
IDE für Rust
Erstmal
Erstmal hier updaten
Die Toolbox darf auch updaten
Genau und normalerweise
Hab ich das immer mit dieser Library hier gemacht
Und die ist in Go
Die ist in Go
Und eine Sache, die mich in Go
Immer genervt hat, ist Stripes, danke schön für den Sub
Eine Sache, die mich in Go
Immer genervt hat, ist
Dass Go
Interopt mit anderen Sprachen
So langsam ist
Die IDE ist absoluter Müll
Echt, hast du schon ausprobiert?
Wie heißt denn das Ding überhaupt?
Hier, Rust Rover
Was verwendest du, wenn das kacke ist?
Meistens sind die Jetbrains
Singer doch immer ganz gut, ja
Zumindest Goland ist nice
Und Rider ist nice
Oh Max
Was macht Visual Studio Code besser?
Plätzchen, Stealth
Easy Light, keine Ahnung was die da treiben
Das denke ich persönlich auch
Es würde mich wegen der interessieren
Was Mr. Robot nicht gefallen hat, beziehungsweise
Was ist denn wie das Code besser ist?
Okay, Update ist raus, installieren wir das
Das Ding buggt in der VR manchmal ein bisschen
Also, nachdem ich meine Plätzchen weggestellt habe jetzt
Kann ich weiter erzählen
Genau und die Library, die ich immer
Wie gesagt, ich sage euch gleich
Wir machen heute nicht viel WebRTC
Wenn überhaupt, gar nicht
Es ist nur nicht, wie ich auf die Idee gekommen bin
Und zwar, für WebRTC habe ich immer diese Library hier verwendet
Aber eine Sache, die mich an Go aufrufen aus anderen Sprachen
Immer extrem abgefuckt hat, ist
Dass das, wenn man das öfters callt, ziemlich langsam ist
Es gibt zwei Varianten
Wenn man aus Go selber C-Funktionen aufruft
Also quasi von Go auf Go
Andere Sprachen aufruft
Dann ist das langsam
Aber es hält sich noch halbwegs in Grenzen
Wenn man aus anderen Sprachen in Go reincallt
In Go-Code reincallt
Dann ist das in der Vergangenheit zumindest extrem langsam gewesen
Also, wir reden hier von
Ein Native Function Call von C-Sharp nach C-Sharp dauert
Was weiß ich
Keine Ahnung
Eine halbe Nanosekunde oder so?
Es ist kurz
Und ein Call nach Go rein dauert irgendwie 300 Nanosekunden
Also, Go ist sehr langsam
Wenn es um Interop mit anderen Sprachen angeht
Das hat mich immer genervt, weil
Ich sende mehrfach
Also ich sende 30 mal die Sekunde pro Kamera
Neue Video Frames nach Go und die WebRTC Library verarbeitet
Die dann
Im Endeffekt
Ich habe, sag mal, wenn du 30 FPS pro Kamera hast
Hast 10 Kameras
Was sagst du, hast du 100 Kameras?
Hast du 3000 Function Calls die Sekunde
Das ist nicht viel
Und das ist auch, ganz ehrlich
Selbst wenn es richtig, richtig langsam ist in Go
Nicht so wirklich das Bottleneck
Aber mich nervt
Deswegen wollte ich das erstens mal ausprobieren
Naja
Also es gibt noch nichts zu rewriten in Rust
Aber wir probieren das mal in Rust aus
Also zumindest wir machen heute kein komplettes WebRTC-Example
Vielleicht im nächsten Stream oder so
Aber das geht erstmal zum ausprobieren
Zumindest
Wollte ich erstmal ausprobieren
Ob das schneller geworden ist mittlerweile
Also C und Go Interop
Ich sag C stellvertretend
Für alle anderen Sprachen die es gibt
Weil jede Sprache
Oder sagen wir so
Mir fällt keine Sprache ein
Die nicht
Interop mit C macht
Wie C Funktionen aufruft
Hat sich so ein bisschen als Standard etabliert
In der Programmierwelt
Ist egal ob das jetzt Python ist
Node
C Sharp
Was auch immer
Alle können sie eigentlich
Dynamisch C Funktionen aufrufen
Also mir fällt keine Sprache ein
Die nicht
C Funktionen aufrufen kann
Sagen wir mal
Kompilierte Sachen
Die mit C Interop
Interface rausgefallen sind
Und das Ding ist
Ich hab irgendwas im Auge
Das ist wirklich richtig nervig
So und
Das Ding ist
Wir testen jetzt erstmal
Ob das schneller geworden ist
Mit Go
Was hab ich eigentlich für eine Go Version drauf hier
Go minus minus Version
Sieht man das
Ah ne das ist die Minus Minus Minus Version nur so
Ne das ist einfach nur Version
Warum macht jetzt eigentlich jeden
Command Line Tool
Irgendwie anders
Das ist so
Bei Java ist es glaube ich
Minus groß V
Oder so
Das kann man sich ja echt nicht merken
So und Rust müssen wir auch gleich mal installieren
Ne Rust ist schon installiert
So
Und
Das
Der Kompilierer für die deutsche Programmiersprache
Oh je
Ja das mit dem einen
Mit dem einen Minus
Ist in der Go Welt
Voll verbreitet
Ich versteh es ehrlich gesagt nicht
Man hätte sich da ein bisschen an Lilux Standards halten können
Und Lilux Standard ist
Minus Minus ausgeschrieben
Einfaches Minus mit Abkürzung
Aber Go hat sich gedacht
Scheiß drauf wir lassen das einfach
Und
Wobei in dem Fall ist es ja sogar nicht nur einfaches Minus
Sondern sogar
Ganz ohne Minus also Sub Command
Leute wartet mal
Muss mal kurz
Wasser ins Auge machen ey
Ey Champ gefixt
Hoffe ich
Aber geht das auch so
Wobei bei Git bin ich es gewöhnt
Ich finde das gar nicht so schlimm
Man muss sich einfach nur dran gewöhnen
Dass Sub Commands sind
Aber Version finde ich halt doof als Sub Command
Minus Minus Version ist einfach viel intuitiver
So also das ist das erste was ich ausprobieren will
Ob Go Interop mit anderen Sprachen immer noch so langsam ist
Und dann
Ja dann kam das nächste wie ich auf Rust gekommen bin
Ich hab gesehen
Das es eine Rust
Reimplementation
Von dieser Go Library
Gibt in Rust
Also das Ding ist ziemlich beliebt
11.900 Sterne und das da
3500 Sterne also fast so viel
Wie der Fiat Champ
Hat da jemand sein Issue geschlossen kann das sein
Guck mal ich sag doch
Keine Fehler im Fiat Champ
Einfach immer
Versteht keiner wie man es verwendet
So und dann hab ich gefunden
Dass es eine Reimplementierung
Von dieser WebRTC Library in Rust gibt
Und dann hab ich mir überlegt
Okay jetzt wärs doch mal an der Zeit
Bevor ich irgendwie
Eine der beiden Libraries benutze
Mal zu gucken
Was sich prinzipiell angenehmer aus .NET
Aufrufen lässt Rust oder Go
Ich persönlich tippe drauf
Dass es meilenweit Rust
Sein wird
Sowohl easy easier zu benutzen
Als auch also nicht zu schreiben
Sondern anzusprechen
Es ist auch deutlich höhere Performance
Vom Callen von C-Sharp aus
Aber so sicher
Ganz sicher bin ich mir nicht
Ich geh aber davon aus dass Rust meilenweit vorne sein wird
Das Problem an Rust ist
Dass Rust absolut abfuck zu schreiben ist
Aber
Der Interop mit C-Sharp
Sollte schneller sein
Deswegen probieren wir das jetzt überhaupt gar nicht
Leute
Ich bin ja schon seit MW1
Der Meinung dass das Kreativität
Komplett bankrott dort ist
MW2
War schon nochmal der Aufguss
Remake Aufguss
Und MW3 komplett
Ich hab heute bei Huskers in den Stream reingeguckt
Hab festgestellt
Die haben zwar teilweise Karten dabei
Aber das Gameplay was ich sehe
Ist das gleiche
Up Aim
MW1
Reboot Gameplay
Mit ultra hoher Time to Kill
Also niedriger
Also ich hab's
Ich hab mir null davon angeguckt
Das interessiert mich nicht
Findest du ernsthaft
Ich find Rust ist eklig
Sowohl Go als auch Rust sind jetzt nicht gerade die schönsten Sprachen
Aber ich find Rust extrem umständlich
Deswegen werden wir das jetzt mal ausprobieren
So also
Hey Max
Kannst du eventuell berichten wie es in dem Bankenwesen
Seine Ausbildung zum Anwendungsinformatiker zu machen
Weiß ich nicht
Ich hab keine Ausbildung gemacht
Bei der Versicherung
Ich habe bei einem Internet Provider
Meine Ausbildung gemacht
Da hatte ich
Nicht direkt zumindest
Was damit zu tun
Nein du solltest dich dort bewerben
Wo die Stelle möglichst vielversprechend aussieht
Ich mein der Laden
Dass der dir vielleicht zusagen sollte
Ist nicht verkehrt
Aber bewerb dich ruhig bei einer Bank
Oder bei einer Versicherung oder sowas
Finanzbranche ist gut
Wenn du deinen Fuß in der Tür hast
Es gibt so eine Tabelle
Ich glaub das erste waren Banken
Das zweite waren Versicherungen
Das dritte war Pharmaindustrie in Deutschland
Ich glaub das vierte Automobilindustrie
Oder sowas für IT Kräfte
Es könnte auch umgedreht gewesen sein
Es könnte auch zuerst Automobil
Und dann Pharmaindustrie
Aber erster Platz, zweiter Platz war auf jeden Fall Banken
Und zweiter war Versicherung
Das heißt wenn du in der Finanzbranche irgendwie deinen Fuß in die Tür kriegst
Ist sinnvoll
Und meistens
Sind die auch ein bisschen größer
Was oftmals echt von Vorteil für die Ausbildung ist
Also
Je nachdem was für eine kleine Klitsche das hier ist
Da wird halt sehr viel so auf
Gut meinen gemacht
Ob es dann gut ist
Weiß man nicht
Bei den großen Läden kommt es halt weniger
Oft vor
Dass keiner Plan hat
Wie das bei einer Ausbildung laufen soll
Dass du keinen Ansprechpartner hast
Dass sich keiner um dich kümmert
Das hast du bei großen Läden weniger
Und dann hast du in der Finanzbranche einen Fuß in der Tür
Weil die bezahlen einfach gut
Also ganz ehrlich
Wenn du die Möglichkeit hast das zu machen
Würde ich mir das angucken
So sieht es aus
Jetzt habe ich erklärt was wir machen wollen
Jetzt probieren wir das ganze mal aus
Also wir legen mal ein neues Projekt an
Also wie gesagt
Wir fangen ganz simpel an
Wir machen ein Go-Projekt
Exportieren dort
Eine Funktion die nichts macht
Rufen die von C-Sharp auf
Und wir machen ein Rust Projekt
Mit einer leeren Funktion
Und rufen die von C-Sharp aus
Und dann benchmarken wir das erstmal
Und gucken was da schneller ist
Beim reinen Function Call
Da wissen wir auch schon mal
Dass das nicht daran liegt
Dass die eine Sprache irgendwas besser kann
Als die andere Sprache in der Implementierung
Sondern einfach so der reine Funktionsaufruf
Mal gucken wie schnell der ist
Man würde erwarten dass der saumäßig schnell ist
Vielleicht nicht so schnell wie der Native Aufruf
Aber immer noch schnell
Ich weiß aber aus Erfahrung
Das Go Interop mit anderen Sprachen
Echt problematisch war
In der Vergangenheit
Gerade wenn das was ist was wirklich
Hunderttausendfach aufgerufen wird
Die haben
Große Unternehmen haben Ausbildungsverantwortlichen
Da passiert sowas eigentlich selten
Danke
Was ist für dich groß
50 Mann sind nicht groß
100 und 200 Mann sind auch nicht wirklich groß
Ich bin mir nicht sicher
Ob das eine T-Bait Frage ist
Oder ernst gemeint
Egal ich sag dazu nix
Weil wenn ich damit anfange
Dann hör ich heute nicht mehr auf
Das muss nicht sein
So dann legen wir mal los
Ich leg mal neues
Benchmark Champ
Wir testen jetzt erstmal
Wie schnell das ganze ist
Und wenn das in Rust wirklich
Und das ist ja zu erwarten
So viel schneller ist
Dann kann ich das ganze WebRTC in Rust programmieren
Wobei ich weiß jetzt schon
Das ich durchdrehen werde dabei
Ein gutes hat's
Das ist quasi eine
Rust Reimplementation
Von der
Go Library hier
Das heißt ich hoffe
Wenn man die Go Library ein bisschen kennt
Kommt man ja auch ganz gut klar
Müssen wir mal schauen
Das ist ziemlich groß
Da gibt es doch eigentlich Ausbildungsbeauftragte
Und Leute die dann
Das es so
Reingeschissen wird
Bei großen Unternehmen was Ausbildung angeht
Das sehe ich eher gehäufter bei den kleinen
Okay
Wir installieren mal eine neue .NET Version
Wird mal Zeit
Weil ich glaube es gibt eine neue Preview Version
Wenn ich das richtig sehe
Ja es gibt
Wobei 100 haben die glaube ich immer
RC2
RC2 23502.2
Sag mal .NET Team
Wie viele Versionsnummern wollt ihr eigentlich noch haben
8.0
Das lass ich mir ja noch gefallen
8.0.100
Ist schon ein bisschen pepege aber auch noch okay
Aber 8.0.100
Minus RC2
.23502.2
Also
Irgendwann ist auch mal gut
Also ich mein bis hierhin geht's ja irgendwie
Nur halbwegs klar
Aber das dahinter ist schon komplett bescheuert
Das hat dann mit
M wäre auch nix mehr zu tun
Weil das interessiert Microsoft eh nicht
Also .NET
New Console
Wir machen mal
Wir machen mal ein paar neue Ordner
Mkdir Rust
Mkdir Go
Mkdir Benchmark
So irgendwie
Benchmark legen wir das
Das .NET Projekt an
Wow
Wer interessiert Blazor
Wer auch immer das benutzt
Also Microsoft will das zurzeit
Boosten wie sonstwas
Aber auch wenn ich
Großer C Sharp Fan bin
Ehrlich im Browser wie es bisher ist
Brauch ich das nicht
So dann haben wir hier Go und haben Rust
Dann kopieren wir uns mal das Verzeichnis
Und ich würd sagen
Dann fangen wir mal ganz easy an
Mit
Und öffnen wir das mal in Rider
Und tun mal so als wüssten wir was von machen
So Repos wie hab ich das genannt
Benchmark
Champ
Ah hier da öffnen
So hier
Auf dem vierten Bildschirm machen wir Go Land auf
Und auf dem fünften
Auf dem fünften
Boah das kostet Ramm Leute
Das kostet Ramm
3 Jetbrain Ideen ist offen
MonkaS Java
Und hier machen wir das Rust Ding auf
I confirm that I have Red Angst
Ja ja ja ich
Ich confirme alles hier
Wir wollen nix senden
Ok New Project was haben wir hier
Rust Version detected 173.0
Ja perfekt top
Wir wollen allerdings
Location Repos
Benchmark Champ
Rust
Da wollen wir rein
Binary Application
Standard Library
Egal
Die Standard Library von dieser Version halt
Weiß nicht wo die ist
Rust
Zack Create
Let's go
Oh geht ja gut los
Erstmal Minischrift
Und als nächstes irgendwelche komischen Errors
Nice
Rust am Start
Cargo failed
Sync Rust Project
Retrieving Rust Standard Lib
Hä warum muss er die noch retrieven bitte schön
Rust kommt mit der Standard Library dabei
Deswegen heißt es Standard Library
Rust up not found
Ja und jetzt
Was der Rust up braucht
Damit das hier funktioniert
Ich kann auch Rust up installieren wenn es sein muss
Easy
Tag installieren wir Rust up
Auch gut
Deinstallieren wir Rust installieren wir Rust up
Top
Ist jetzt Cargo und so da
Run Rust
Default Stable
Ok nice
Also das mag ich
Das mag ich an Rust
Ich hab ja auch nicht so viel
Ich hab ausgemacht
Und ab und zu
Ich muss jetzt mal
Ich muss jetzt rufen
Da wird ausgeliefert
Das ist z.B.
Screenplay
Einfach
Da wird es
Genau so
Also jetzt mal
anderen Sprachen. Zumindest war das in der Vergangenheit
so.
Es wird aufgerufen, C-Sharp nach Go
und C-Sharp nach Rust. Es wird
nicht C-Sharp Go Rust aufgerufen.
Es wird C-Sharp nach Go und dann C-Sharp nach Rust
aufgerufen. Wir gucken mal, was schneller ist. Ich tippe
einfach, dass Rust in allen Belangen
komplett meilenweit ahead
of Go ist, weil Go bekannt
dafür ist, dass Go langsam ist als Interop
mit anderen Sprachen. Also langsamer als ziemlich
jede andere halbwegs
bekannte Programmiersprache. Und Go ist
super langsam, was das angeht.
Also das ist langsamer als so ziemlich
jede andere Sprache, die mir so einfällt.
Das ist langsamer als
Python, langsamer
also nur in diesem einen Fall, ja.
Also Callen
von und nach anderen
Sprachen über irgendein C-Interface.
Das ist langsamer als Python,
als Java, als
alles einfach nur.
JavaScript.
Das ist wirklich
Go ansonsten ist ja recht flott,
aber in dem Bereich ist es wirklich
PP.
Mega langsam. So, also
hat es jetzt, jetzt
starten wir nochmal dieses Rust-Ding, ob das jetzt
besser funktioniert, nachdem ich Rust-Up installiert
habe. Ja, nice, scheint zu funktionieren.
Was hat Go für Vorteile?
Go hat ein paar
Vorteile. Zum Beispiel ist Go relativ
flott.
Wie gesagt, was langsam ist, ist ja nur diese
eine Sache, die ich gerade gesagt habe.
Champshifter, danke für den Sub.
Ansonsten ist Go relativ
flott. Go ist
richtig gut, wenn man
Self-Contained Binaries haben
möchte, die rückwärtskompatibel einfach auf jedem
Linux-System laufen. Da ist Go so
ziemlich die beste Sprache, die es gibt,
die existiert, die man dafür
benutzen kann.
Auch im Cloud-Umfeld
ist Go sehr beliebt.
Warum kann ich die Font-Size nicht ändern?
Und?
Ach, jetzt geht's auf einmal, okay.
Okay, JetBrains
Mono, meinetwegen.
Oh, aber ich glaube,
die Schriftgröße ist ganz okay, oder?
Ich glaube, Jetge,
ich muss mal kurz in meiner Vorschau...
Ja, die Schriftgröße ist gut.
Ich sehe das gerade hier in der Vorschau, die ist okay.
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Das ist eigentlich sehr angenehm zu lesen
gerade. Ich gucke mir das gerade auf der
Vorschau-Monitor an.
Auch nettes, recht
nicht so ins Augen brennende
Dark-Theme dabei, das ist okay.
So, MainPrint,
hallo World, ja, das kommt schon mal weg.
Wir brauchen gar keine Main-Funktion.
Ach,
so, ja, Moment, ich muss das ja
umstellen auf eine Library.
Wir legen erst mal das Go-Projekt an.
Was haben wir hier noch offen?
New Session, New Message,
Create Session, New Sender.
Ach so, ah, ich weiß,
das ist, ja, ja, ja, das haben wir mal
gebaut, naja, das können wir wegmachen.
Da müssen wir ein neues Projekt anlegen.
Also legen wir ein neues
Go-Projekt an.
Wo ist das hier? Go,
New Project,
und zwar wollen wir
nach Repos
Benchmark Champ
Go. Und jetzt wollen wir
ein Go-Modules-Projekt
anlegen. Ich glaube, das macht er standardmäßig.
Was ist
Enable Vendoring Support?
Äh, verstehe ich
nicht.
Sollte ich das an- oder ausschalten?
Ich verstehe die Hilfe nicht.
Kann weg.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es mir überhaupt sagen soll,
ehrlich gesagt. Okay, ihr habt auch
keine Ahnung. Wenn der Chat keine Ahnung hat,
dann beruhigt mich das immer.
Okay, create this window.
Close. So, jetzt muss ich
erstmal gucken, dass ich wieder ein bisschen
anfange, Go zu checken.
Go war doch so.
So, wir gehen jetzt mal Repo,
Benchmark Champ, Go.
Und jetzt sagen wir
Go run.
Und dann kackt's ab.
Weil
Missing Go Version Modload.
Nice.
Ach so, es fehlt eine Main, oder?
Einfach eine Main-Datei. Dann ist die Fehlermeldung
aber pepega as fuck.
Also, new Go-File
main.go
package
Moment, warum heißt das Projekt
Go? Das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn.
Das Projekt soll
heißen... Ach so, das heißt so
wie der Ordner.
Und das hier heißt auch Rust.
Es sollte durchaus auch okay sein, dass das
heißt. So, Package Main muss das
ja sein, weil wir sind ja hier in Go.
Und dann braucht man...
Function Main.
Und dann sagen wir sowas wie FMT
Brindeln
Keg Wait. So, und das sollte
jetzt kompilieren, oder? Nein.
Warum nicht?
Das darf bestimmt nicht so heißen, oder?
Das ist bestimmt pepega, weil der Ordner
Go heißt. Garantiert kann das das nicht
ab, weil der Ordner Go heißt. Könnte ich wetten
mit euch. Was?
Go Mod Init? Das muss man doch
normalerweise nie machen.
Äh.
Mod?
Das ist 100
Pro. Ich wette mit euch.
Das ist, weil der Ordner Go heißt.
Go hat so komische
Dinger. Das kann ich mir richtig
gut vorstellen.
Wir löschen das nochmal.
Man sieht ja ins Terminal nicht. Ja, in dem Fall
gibt es da eh nichts. Wir löschen
das nochmal und machen MKT
Go App. Okay? So.
Das sollte nicht
problematisch sein.
Also, New Project.
Jetzt hat er das schon wieder.
Lass ich das mal enabled. Vielleicht macht es das dann
richtig. So, wir wollen
nach Benchmark Champ
Go App. Und eigentlich
da rein direkt. Genau.
Create.
Und jetzt sage ich
Go App. Go Run Punkt.
Ja, siehste? Siehste? Jetzt funktioniert
es auch. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das an diesem
automatischen Vendoring Support
lag. Was auch immer das macht.
Oder weil das Ding. Ich tippe auf den Ordner
Namen. Ich tippe auf den. Bei Go weißt
du nie. Go hat so viele
Magic Sachen, die so sein müssen.
Weil sie so sein müssen. Beispielsweise auch Klammern
bei einem If oder so. Dass ich mir das gut
vorstellen kann. So, Main Punkt
Go. So, das ist
auch merkwürdig gemacht, dass das
nicht so heißen darf wie die App, sondern
So, und jetzt machen wir hier
Function Main
FMT Prindeln
Keg Wait. So, und das sollte
jetzt funktionieren. Ja, okay.
Nice. Funktioniert. Mal kurz checken,
ob Rust auch funktioniert.
Seht ihr das Terminal hier, wenn ich da
was tippe? Leute, hier unten. Sieht man
das?
Ne, da ist der Chat davor, gell?
Dann machen wir es so. Wir machen so. Dann
seht ihr es auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt ist genug Platz unter Chico
hier rechts. Da sieht man nichts.
Dann machen wir auch das Terminal
hier unten drunter.
So, ja.
Also, Repos, Benchmark, Champ,
Rust.
Und jetzt machen wir mal, ich glaube
Cargo Run ist es.
Okay, Rust
Kompiliert fehlerfrei
Erstmal im Kalender anmarken
Tja
Jetzt geht's schon los
Ich glaube
Es ist Brindeln, ne
Auch in Rust
Kick, wait
Okay, ja, funktioniert, nice
Okay, also
Jetzt kommt das nächste
Also das ist jetzt ja einfach nur um zu gucken
Ob alles richtig aufgesetzt ist
So
Also, das Ding, was hat er hier für Schmerzen
Could not load
Ah ja
Das liegt, nicht toll
Bild
Das liegt daran, dass er meine .NET Version
Nicht erkannt hat, warum auch immer
Reload
Project, jetzt sollte es hoffentlich
Gleich gehen, machen wir auch nochmal
Eine Konsole auf
CD, Repos, Benchmark
.NET
Run
Ja, Funst, okay
Alles klar
So, also, was ich jetzt vorhabe
Ist folgendes
Ich möchte jetzt sowas hier machen
Ich will jetzt
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen
Wir machen mal den .NET Teil
Als erstes
Und dann den anderen
Wir machen jetzt mal eine Datei
Interop.cs
Die kriegt eine Public
Eine
Unsave
Public Static Class
Warum Unsave?
Naja, weil ich
C-Sachen mit Pointern und so
In anderen Sprachen aufrufen will
Also das muss Unsave sein
Und damit das funktioniert
Muss ich Unsave erlauben
Ich weiß eh nicht, warum das nicht
Standardmäßig an ist
Ich meine, wenn man es nicht verwendet, verwendet man es halt nicht
So
Und jetzt will ich
Beispielsweise sowas hier aufrufen
DLL Import
Von, ja
Rusty
Slip
Will ich aufrufen
Eine Funktion, die
Boah, DLL Import Syntax
Moment
Muss ich mir abgucken
Ich glaube Static Extern oder irgendwie so muss das aussehen
Public Static Extern
Genau
So, Public Static Extern
Das heißt ja auch hier irgendwie
Call me, so
Einfach nur Call heißt das Ding
Also, was das macht
Das ist was noch nicht geht, weil es ist noch nicht da
Damit kann ich jetzt aus C-Sharp
Eine Funktion aufrufen, die in Rust
In einer Library
In einer
In einer Rust Library, die mit C-Interface
Kompiliert wurde, existiert
Aufrufen
Void fehlt noch
Und hiermit
Kann ich, achso die sollte ich vielleicht
Ein bisschen anders nennen
Call me Rust
Call oder einfach nur Call
Go und
Ich muss nur gucken, dass die Libraries
Am Ende dann richtig heißen
Also das sucht jetzt nach einer Library
Die Rustlib heißt, irgendwo hier im Verzeichnis
Oder Golib, die gibt es noch nicht
Die müssen wir anlegen
Und dort drinnen ruft es dann eine Funktion auf
Die heißt Call Go
Und Call Rust
Das wird erstmal eine leere Funktion sein
Man kann mit C-Sharp DLLs erstellen
Nein, man kann aber
Native Funktionen
Importieren, beziehungsweise aufrufen
In DLLs
Oder in unter Linux sind das
.so Dateien vorhanden sind
Also Dynamic Loading
So und mein Ziel
Ist dann sowas zu machen hier
Interop
Punkt Call
Call Rust
Wenn ich das jetzt aufrufe, wird folgendes passieren
Bam
Er findet nämlich Golib
Und ähm
Rustlib nicht
Aber auch klar, die haben wir noch nicht angelegt
Die gibt es schlicht und ergreifend noch gar nicht
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal mit dem Go Teil an
Da weiß ich noch
Ungefähr, so ganz grob
Wie es aussehen muss
Dass das funktioniert
Und zwar, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe
Muss man jetzt folgendes machen
Also wir legen jetzt mal in Go was an
Die Main Funktion brauchen wir nicht
Weil wir starten ja
Kein Binary, sondern
Wir callen von C-Sharp in was rein
Was in Go definiert ist
Ist natürlich auch der Einstiegspunkt
Nicht Main, sondern der Einstiegspunkt in dem Fall ist
Call Go, weil das ist das was wir aufrufen
So, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe
Wie das funktioniert in Go
Dann sagt man hier Function
Die muss heißen Call Go
So wie hier
Also so wie da
Und dann muss man glaube ich drüber schreiben
Export
Call Go
Entweder mit Leerzeichen, ne ohne Leerzeichen
Und ich glaube
So muss man das machen
Man muss das als C-Interface exportieren
Aber das war noch nicht alles
Go run
Ne das geht natürlich nicht
Oh shit
Go kompilieren
Als C-Library
Beziehungsweise mit C-Interface
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal
Oh meine Güte
Muss ich nachgucken
C-Go-Compile
Ach Import C musste man auch noch machen
Ja ja ok
Das musste man auch noch machen
Am Anfang
Also das braucht man
Das braucht man in Go
Damit man aus Go C-Libraries aufrufen kann
Und das hier braucht man
Damit man aus anderen Sprachen
Go Sachen aufrufen kann
Über ein C-Interface was generiert wird
Ich glaube man braucht beides oder
Egal schadet auf jeden Fall nichts
Was auch immer
Das da jetzt ist
Keine Ahnung
Äh
What the
Ich such den Go-Build Aufruf dafür
Go-Build
Man muss irgendwie C-Go-Enable oder sowas machen
Ich hab das noch
Ich hab das noch im Hinterkopf irgendwie
Go-Build
Ich weiß aber nur nicht mehr
Hab ich das vielleicht hier irgendwo
Ne
Hab ich das vielleicht in der anderen VM
Noch als History
Kann GCC auch Go kompilieren
Ja
Es gibt ein GCC Plugin für Go
Aber das verwendet glaube ich
Meines Wissens nach so gut wie niemand
C-Go
Gleich
Ah Shit haben wir es auch nicht
In der History mal drin
Oh wie war das denn jetzt nochmal
Hier C-Go-Enable genau
Ganz ehrlich ich versteh auch gar nicht
Wozu das gut sein soll
Ja C-Go-Enable genau das such ich
C-Go-Enable
Aber die Frage ist wie man es jetzt nochmal aufruft
Env
Go-OS-Linux
C-Go-Enable
Ok
Das ging irgendwie so
Ne es ist auf jeden Fall Env
Da unter C
C-Go-Enable
Gleich 1
Und dann sagt man glaube ich einfach Go-Build
Ne
Aber ich bin ja auch falsch hier
Ich muss ja auch in mein Go-Projekt
Ja das wird jetzt ein bisschen abartig bei mir
Bis das funktioniert
Ne im Moment hat er einfach funktioniert gerade
Äh
Nein das ist falsch
Der soll das als Library kompilieren
Äh
Build Mode
Oh meine Güte wie geht das Go
Shared
Shared Library
Shared Libraries in Go
How to use Go Shared Library
Ne ne ne ne
Building Shared Libraries in Go
Shared Libraries in Go
Genau wie ging das nochmal
Ich hab das
Manchmal ist Brain in der History gar nicht so gut
Weil
Wenn man dann seine History nicht hat
Hier
Build Mode gleich C Shared
Minus O Preload
Ich hab keine Ahnung was das bedeuten soll
Ich lass das einfach mal weg
Was
Ok was auch immer
Also wahrscheinlich brauchen wir jetzt noch
Das hier dabei
Go Build hin
Ja schon besser schon besser
Aber wo ist meine Library
Ach Go App ist die Library
Ok das Ding soll heißen
Nach dem es ja
Ok also
Äh
Bin ich
Moment warum ist der Aufruf nicht mehr in meiner History drin
What the
Achso weil ein Leerzeichen davor war
Lul
Ja dann ist klar das das nicht drin steht
Ok Minus O
Minus O
Der Output soll sein
Wie hab ich das genannt in .NET
GoLib
GoLib.so
Ja sehr schön
Genau genau genau
So will ich das haben
Ok GoLib.so
Soll er bauen
Und dann soll er das ganze Moven
GoLib.so
Moven hoch in das
Sharp Projekt
GoLib.so ok
Nice
So wenn ich Glück hab klappt das jetzt schon
Fuck
Cannot open
Ah ich weiß warum
Weil ich
Ppega bin
Ich muss die Build Action auch umstellen
Das der das ins Output Directory kopiert
Und jetzt kommt
Pregge Leute Pregge
Ey es funzt
Ich kann euch auch beweisen das es funzt
Guckt mal
Wir schreiben jetzt hier was in Go rein
Ok
Fmt printeln Lul
Kompilieren das
Und jetzt rufe ich es aus C Sharp auf
Lul
Und ihr seht hier nirgends wo in C Sharp ist Lul definiert
Oder Lul die Ausgabe die kommt aus Go
Also jetzt callt
Jetzt callt C Sharp nach Go rein
Das ist nice
Ähm
Wie mach ich denn
Ein Release Build
Ist das standardmäßig ein Release Build
Ne ne C
Go brauche ich auf jeden Fall
Weil ich will gleich noch versuchen
Wie das ist ob man auch ein Struct returnen kann
Und sowas
Ähm was habe ich gerade gesagt
Was wollte ich gerade machen
Jetzt habe ich gerade an was anderes gedacht Lul
Jetzt weiß ich was ich gerade machen wollte
Ähm Chat was habe ich vor 2 Sekunden gesagt
Lolo alle Boomer hier
Achso Release Build ja
Go Build Release
House of Build
Achso
Strip Debug Symbols
Nö nö nö
Ach ok es gibt gar kein Debug und Release Build
Bei Go gibt es nur
Gibt es nur Release Builds quasi
Was für eine Linungsdistribution ist das
Arch by the way
Wenn du es genau wissen willst
Dafür habe ich natürlich nochmal mein Neo Fetch vorbereitet
Damit ich euch regelmäßig sagen kann
Dass ich Arch Linungs verwende
Das ist Arch Linungs allerdings in der Form
UVM
Und das Terminal ist West Term
Das ist E3 als
Window Manager und ZSH
Als Shell
Wenn es dich
Genau interessiert wie das alles konfiguriert
Ist und funktioniert kannst du auf
Github gucken hier ist meine ganze
Config und wenn du gerade dabei bist
Kann ich dir empfehlen
Schnapp dir auch noch gleich die passenden Desktop Hintergründe
Das du auch
White Paper Happy hast
Im Hintergrund so wie ich
Was ist One Fetch
Ist One Fetch die coolere Neo
Neo Fetch Variante
Oder was
Command Line Git Information Tool
Was ist das
Written in Rust
Natürlich die Krustentiere sind wieder am Start
Ach da kriegt man
Infos über das Repo angezeigt
Ja das ist doch eigentlich auch ganz cool
So
Also das Call nach
Go Code funktioniert schon einmal
So
Wir können jetzt natürlich noch sagen
.NET Run Minus
C Release
Das es auch im Release Mode läuft
Gut also erster
Part ist geschafft
Jetzt könnt ihr euch aussuchen
Chat ob wir als erstes
Den Go Part
Vollständig bauen also vollständig
Bauen bedeutet zwei Sachen
Leider nicht aus Go die nächste
Programmiersprache Callen
Die nächste Programmiersprache Callen
Also was ich in den
Sprachen machen will
Ich will zwei Sachen jeweils in den Sprachen einbauen
Und zwar das erste ist
Eine leere Funktion die wir aufrufen können
In dem Fall kommt das mit dem 0 wieder raus
Weil ich will nicht 500 mal 0 ausgeben
Und
Das zweite ist eine Funktion
Die nennen wir einfach hier irgendwie Call Go 2
Und die soll ein Struct
Returnen
Und da bin ich mal gespannt wie ich das
Mache ein Struct
Von Go zu Return in C Sharp
Was man dann da dort
Auch als Struct quasi
Deserialisieren kann und benutzen kann
Das einfachste wäre natürlich alle seine Daten
Irgendwie als JSON String zu Returnen
Und dann Parse aber das ist ja langweilig
Wir wollen das ja richtig auf C Ebene machen
Also quasi Memory Bytes
Dann
Casten zu irgendeinem Struct
Da bin ich mal gespannt wie das geht ich hab kein Plan
Ne auch nicht GRPC
Das ist wirklich richtig richtig Low Level
Soll das sein
So
Also ihr könnt euch jetzt aussuchen
Wollen wir jetzt den Go Part noch implementieren
Also sprich die Funktion in Go
Die in den Struct zurück liefert an C Sharp
Oder wollen wir jetzt erstmal gucken
Wie man Rust
Callen kann von C Sharp aus
Könnt ihr euch aussuchen
Ich trink mal was
Rust erstmal Go fertig
Go fertig
Okay
Also
Die meisten Leute wollen Go haben
Ich denke dass es nicht so lange dauert
Wobei ich das noch nicht gemacht habe
Structs Returnen
Von Go nach C Sharp
Ich würde sagen wir fangen mal easy an
Okay wir fangen mal easy an
Easy heißt
Wir returnen hier jetzt ein
Moment wie
Ach shit wie ging das nochmal
Ich glaube einfach
Sagen wir mal
In den UN64
Returnen wir jetzt hier mal
So
Und jetzt sagen wir hier
Return 1
Mein einfacher geht es nicht mehr
Kompiliert auch ohne Fehler
Und jetzt ist die Frage
Das dürfte ziemlich easy sein
Jetzt gehe ich hier einfach hin
Ich kommentiere mal das Rust aus
Jetzt ist der Return Typ nicht void
Sondern der Return Typ ist UN64
Das Ding ist nur
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Ich glaube das ist ein
C aus Go
Exportiert ein C UNt
Die gleiche ist
Moment geht das überhaupt so
Das geht doch eigentlich gar nicht
Ich will ja kein Rust UNt
Exportieren
Sondern ein C UNt
UN64
Also es könnte sein dass das funktioniert
Wenn die Implementierung einfach überall
Gleich sind
Probieren wir das mal aus
Aber ich glaube nicht dass das funktioniert
Ups
Da sollte jetzt 1 rauskommen
Das funktioniert aber ich glaube ganz
Korrekt ist das nicht
Das funktioniert wirklich nur
Weil das Memory Layout
Von einem UN64 einfach in C Sharp
Und Go gleich ist
Ich glaube korrekter wäre
Hier gewesen zu returnen ein
C.UN64
Oder sowas
Gibt es
Wie heißt das T oder so
Ist das so
Uint64C
Wie heißt das Kram
Uint64T
Habe ich doch
Gibt es nicht
Was muss ich denn da
Includen dafür
Standard
Stdint.h
Hey Funst
Nice
Ok also einzelne ins return
Von Go nach C
Von Go
Über C nach C Sharp
Funst
Jetzt ist die Frage
Wie machen wir das mit einem Struct
Das wird bestimmt etwas komplizierter
Könnte ich mir vorstellen
Weil wir brauchen ja
Wir brauchen ja einen C Struct
Kein Go Struct
Ok Go Struct
To C
Struct
Layouts sind in C Sharp
Recht easy
Wenn du dem sagst das er
Wie heißt das
Sequenziell serialisieren soll
Dann ist es das gleiche Layout wie von C
Dann ist das eigentlich kein Ding
Hoff ich mal
Ja genau genau das meine ich
Ja damit ist das
Meistens nicht so ein großes Problem
Go lang Struct
With C Struct
Ok ok ok
Ne der hat nen
Go Struct
Mit C Types drinnen
Das will ich nicht
Ok C Go
Return Struct
How to return Struct
Vom C Go
Ja genau das will ich haben
I have found a solution
In C
Ok der definiert ein Struct in C
Gibt es nicht C Pack Unpack
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Pack?
How to return a C Struct from a Go Function
Genau das will ich wissen
Ok Struct Point
Man muss das in C definieren
Auf jeden Fall
To access a Struct
Type directly
Prefix it with Struct
Underscore
Ok C Punkt Struct
Oh meine Güte
Also ich glaube das wird in Rust
Eigentlich angenehmer sein
Als in Go
Also sprich wir brauchen jetzt
Ne Moment das muss man
So
Und das muss soweit ich weiß
Dann auch direkt über Import C stehen
Sonst mag er nicht
So die Includes können wir dann hier rein machen
Massive Pepega
So jetzt haben wir nen Struct Point
Wir wollen allerdings nicht Point Return
Wir wollen ein Struct
Ok machen wir einfach mal sowas hier
Struct Session
Hat eine
Wir machen mal was was man später auch irgendwie
Sinnvoll irgendwie
So das einmal gibt es hier ein
Int
Oder ein
U
Int machen wir es mal so
Ein Uint64T
Client ID
Und
Dann gibt es oh jetzt wird es interessant
Jetzt gibt es nen String
Den nennen wir
Keine Ahnung Name oder so
Ja Client Name
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Wie ich ein Struct
Mit nem
Sharp Pointer
Irgendwie rüber kriege ins die Sharp
Ohne
Wohlgemerkt
Ohne Memory Leaks zu verursachen
Das wird
Oje
Ich weiß ja nicht einmal
Wie ich das über ok Return
Also wie ging das jetzt
C Punkt Struct Underscore
Und dann Session
Und jetzt durfte ich
Das so benennen mit
Ehm
Client Name
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht wie ist die Syntax
X
Variable Variable zuerst
Ok
Also Client ID
So das ist jetzt ein C Char
Array oder so
Ich hoffe
Das
Ne ne das funktioniert schon mal nicht
Oje
Wie ist das syntaktisch denn richtig
Ne das ist eigentlich ok so
Und dann haben wir noch was
Ich weiß einen Moment Client ID
Client ID ist 123
Und dann haben wir noch Client Name
Client Name ist dann 0w
Das wird so definitiv nicht funktionieren
Leute das kann ich euch sagen
Das wird nicht funktionieren
Ok das funktioniert schon mal nicht
Also
Das ist falsch weil das ist ja auch
Ein Uint
Also das hier muss ja auch
Ein sowas hier sein
Moment meine Go
Skills verlassen mich ich glaube das geht so
Das das funktioniert
Ja
Ne
Achso Moment
Ich return ja gar kein Struct
Ich will das hier return
Ok schon besser
Schon besser hätte ich es auch einfach so
Returnen können ohne das der rummeckert
Anscheinend
So also das funktioniert nicht
Ich muss jetzt einen
Charakter Array
In Go mach ok
Äh
C String
C Go return wie fandst du das
Return String
C Function in Go legen
C Punkt
C String
Was ich mache
Ich rufe aus C Sharp Go
Code auf über ein C Interface
Also
Irgendwie sowas wie
C String
Ne Moment
Wir sind
Ne
Go
Ne Moment
Zu viele Programmiersprachen auf einmal
So oder
Ok
Leute es
Es kompiliert
Client Name ist
HDXYZ123
Ok
Könnte ein geiles Passwort sein
Ist es aber nicht
Ok jetzt returne ich ein Struct aus Go
Heißt im Endeffekt
Wenn ich das hier aufrufe das sollte noch funktionieren
Weil das erst
Ok das ist schon mal gut
123 ist die Client ID die ich hier gesetzt habe
Das funzt weil in meinem Struct
Vorne immer noch
Die Client ID ist
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage
Wie kriege ich hier raus ein Struct
Also machen wir mal in C Sharp ein Struct
Das nennen wir auch Session
Public
Uint64
Tja
Client ID nennen wir es mal genauso
Public
String
Kann ich mir so nicht vorstellen
Dass das funktioniert
Und selbst wenn es funktioniert
Hat es garantiert Memory Leaks
Das werden wir jetzt mal ausprobieren
Mal gucken
Ob das C Sharp Interoption
Zeug so schlau ist
Und erkennt das man ja aus einem
C String
Ein C Sharp String machen kann
Automatisch
Da bin ich mal gespannt
So und das Ding soll heißen Client Name
Übrigens die Namen hier sind vollkommen egal
Die Namen sind vollkommen wurscht
Die müssen nicht die gleichen sein wie hier
Wichtig ist die Byte Anzahl
Also dass das hier
Quasi so lang ist
Und das hier so lang ist
Dass es dann passt im Endeffekt
Wie das hier heißt ist vollkommen egal
Also das Layout im Speicher muss das gleiche sein
So und jetzt
Returnen wir hiervon kein Uint
Sondern eine Session
Das funktioniert nicht weil es nicht Public ist
Ok Session
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
So Session Client ID
Ich hoffe das geht noch
Ok das funzt
Was ist hier
Client Name
Funktioniert einfach
Moment der erkennt automatisch
Der weiß automatisch wie man ein C String
In ein C Sharp String
Aber das hat 100 pro Memory Leaks
Das hat sowas von Memory Leaks
Leute ich sags euch
100 pro hat das Memory Leaks
Moment Moment
Watch Free minus H
Wir machen jetzt die
Erkenntnis
Wir machen jetzt folgendes
Wir gucken jetzt mal
Ob es Memory Leaks hat
While True
While 0w
Ok so
Wir gucken ob es Memory Leaks hat
Wir rufen es einfach in der Schleife auf
Und gucken ob
Free runter geht
Run
Oh Shit
Ich glaube es hat
Naja nö oder doch
Ah
Das ist jetzt aktuell so gar nicht mal zu
Das ist jetzt echt schwer
Der GC
Kann das nicht freen
Weil der GC wahrscheinlich kein free
Ne ne das hat ein Memory Leak
Oder?
Oder nicht
Also wenn das kein Memory Leak hat
Dann wundert es mich extrem
Warum verursacht es nicht mehr CPU Last
Ne macht es doch
Memory
Wir könnten doch einfach mal mit einem Debugger starten
Schwer zu sagen
Also das könnte auch einfach
Kein Memory Leak
Aber das wundert mich
Woher will es die Sharp wissen
Wie man das
Eigibt
Moment Moment Moment
Habe ich das überhaupt schon kompiliert jetzt
Und dahin geschoben
Wie kann das sein dass das kein Memory Leak gibt
Warum das .NET nicht freeen können soll
Weil .NET nicht zuständig ist dafür
Das zu freeen
Woher möchte .NET wissen
An der Stelle
Dass ich den eigentlichen Pointer auf dem das passiert
Das im Ursprungsprogramm nicht mehr verwende
Wenn ich das selbst
Aufrufen würde dann ist okay
Aber dass das
Automatisch freed wird
Ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn
Aber anscheinend
Anscheinend funktioniert
Das
Also das ist
Mache ich irgendwas falsch
Interop
Hall
Go
Nö
Wir müssen mal kurz was checken
Steht da überhaupt was drin
Session
Name
Ja
Ich bin Leute
Ich bin hochgradig verwirrt
Kann das sein
Dass das einfach rausoptimiert wird
Ich bin echt
Verwirrt und begeistert
Gleichzeitig dass es wohl anscheinend
Memory Leak
Ergibt
Können wir das hier nicht mit dem Debugger starten
Und sehen dann die RAM Auslastung
Also in Visual Studio gibt es
In Visual Studio gibt es einen Debugger mit RAM Auslastung
Ich weiß nicht wie das hier in
In Rider aussieht
Was
Was genau möchte Rider von mir
Wo ist das Problem
Ach hier
Hey Rider was willst du von mir
Was hat der für Schmerzen
Der weiß doch wo mein .NET Zeug liegt
Keine Ahnung
Also ich würde gerne
Das kann man
Das muss doch hier irgendwie funktionieren
Benchmark
Wo ist das Problem
Ja richtig Runtime korrekt
Exec Path korrekt
Der
Ja aber das hier ist doch .NET 8
Stimmt doch eigentlich
Jaja der ruft das nicht
Mit dem richtigen
Mit der richtigen
.NET Installation auf
Was aber äußerst pepega ist
Weil hier checkt das
Hier checkt das
Da ist irgendwas falsch
Jaja
Der benutzt meine System Runtime
Was aber keinen Sinn ergibt
Weil ich überall hier
Überall hier das richtige eingestellt ist
Auch hier 8 guck
Ich glaub irgendwie das bugt rum
Ok
Wir probieren jetzt mal was anderes
Nur um sicherzustellen dass das irgendwie an mir liegt
Und zwar
Guck mal was wir jetzt machen
Das hier ist jetzt einfach kein String
Sondern ein Inpointer
Und spätestens jetzt sollte er es ja nicht aufräumen
So mal gucken ob es jetzt Memory Leaks gibt
Also ich würde sagen
Es gibt Memory Leaks
Jaja
Guck das geht
Das geht steil
Also im Inpointer gibt es Memory Leaks
Aber wenn es ein String ist
Dann gibt das
Automatisch frei geben kann
Das ergibt für mich eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn
Ne guck mal im String checkt er das
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie
Warum die Runtime so 6 Header ist
Aber
Wenn man ihm sagt es ist ein String
Dann freet er das automatisch
Ich bin begeistert
Ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet
Dass das .NET so schlau ist
Und das kapiert
Macht der da unter der Haube irgendwie einen Free drauf
Aber woher weiß er überhaupt
Also das finde ich äußerst
Spannend
Dass das funktioniert
Der checkt das
Hätte ich nicht gedacht
Ich hätte gedacht ich muss das von Hand machen
Also das ist schlau
Also das ist von der Runtime wirklich schlau
Dass der den String hier automatisch freeen kann
Das Ding ist nur
Das eigentlich er das
Eher nicht machen sollte
Weil
Er hat keine Ahnung
Was ich verwende
Zum Beispiel machen wir doch mal was
Machen wir mal folgendes
Machen wir mal hier
Das muss man jetzt mit war machen
Irgendwie so
Und der wird jetzt gefreed
Wobei ne dann ist er wahrscheinlich so schlau
Das ist eine gute Frage
Aha
Entdeckt
Exposed
Ja
Die Runtime ist so schlau
Und ruft wirklich free unter der Haube auf
Für den
Pointer den sie kriegt
Hä
Das hätte ich
Nicht gedacht
Aber da sieht man auch schon
Das kann echt zu Problemen führen
Wenn ich den String noch weiter verwende
In dem drunterliegenden Go Programm
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher
Ob das ein sinnvolles Default Verhalten ist
Dass das immer automatisch
Den Pointer freeet
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher
Wie hast du das rausgefunden
Indem ich das einfach
Einmal global angelegt hab den String
Und immer den gleichen returne
Und jetzt versucht ihr ihn zum zweiten mal zu freeen
Und
Das geht natürlich nicht
Also ihr habt
.NET versucht
Also ich mein okay
In gewisser Logik hat das
.NET erkennt wir bekommen nen Character Pointer
Und
Wandeln den Character Pointer um
Kopieren quasi den Inhalt in den .NET String
Und dann freeen wir den ursprünglichen Pointer
Das ist aber eigentlich gar nicht so ungefährlich
Weil .NET
Weil es das automatisch macht
Weiß doch überhaupt nicht
Ob ich den darunterliegenden Character Pointer
Noch weiter verwende
Hier beispielsweise
Also
Weiß nicht
Da bin ich
Da gehe ich nicht so dacor mit
Was das da macht
Aber soll mir recht sein
In dem Fall funzt es einfach ohne mein zutun
Ja wenn man es nicht direkt als String macht
Das kann man garantiert unterbinden
Wir haben es ja gesehen man kann es schon unterbinden
Indem ich hier einfach nen Inpointer draus mache
Sobald ich hier nen
Inpointer draus mache
Dann wird Memory geleaked as fuck
Guck
Ja 700 MB
960 MB
1,2 Gig
1,4 Gig
1,7 Gig
Also eigentlich hätte ich damit gerechnet
Das ich das eh so machen muss
Das ich den Pointer selbst deserialisieren
Und dann freeen
Also eigentlich dachte ich
Ich muss sowas hier machen sinngemäß
Session
Inpoint
Das ist ja im Prinzip nur nen Pointer
An die Stelle wo das Character Array steht
So und ich dachte mir
Ich muss da jetzt sowas hier machen
Zum Beispiel
UTF-8
Pointer to String UTF-8
Client Name
So wenn ich das mache sollte es auch Memory Leaks geben
Achso
Semicolon
Das sollte auch Memory Leaks geben
Ja ja ja fette fette Memory Leaks
250 MB
Memory Leak pro Sekunde
Ja so und jetzt dachte ich eigentlich
Ich
Kopiere mir das hier in .NET String
Und danach sage ich
Native Memory Free
Das ist was neues
Das gibt es noch nicht so lange in C Sharp
Das ist um die Standard
C Free Funktion aufzurufen in der Hoffnung
Dass der Code von dem ich den Pointer bekomme
Das mit der Standard C Free
Geschichte
Mit der Standard C Alloc
Geschichte allockiert hat
Den Speicher
Also hoffen wir einfach mal
Und jetzt sagen wir hier Session Client Name
Und jetzt sollte ich
Warum nicht
Ach unsave
Geht nicht weil
Muss ein Void Pointer sein
Ok
Jetzt sollte ich auch keine Memory Leaks mehr haben
Weil jetzt mache ich das von Hand
Ich schnappe mir den Pointer
Kopiere den in .NET String
Und dann Free ich den Pointer
So müsste das eigentlich sein
Und siehe da es gibt auch keine Memory Leaks mehr
Also das macht anscheinend
Ernsthaft .NET unter der Haube
Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
Ein bisschen
Merkwürdig
Das es das macht
Sehr komisch
Wir probieren nochmal was
Wir machen jetzt hier nochmal einen String draus
Und dann machen wir das was der Chat sagt
Das interessiert mich nämlich echt
S
Unmanaged
Unmanaged Type nicht Bool
Äh
Char
Ne Moment was gibt es denn da überhaupt
Str
Oh das ist Windows Shit
LP String
A Single By 0 Terminated on the Character Single
Dann haben wir
LPT String
Unicode Character String
What
LPW String
2 Byte
Alles klar
B String
BVAL T String
Alter Microsoft es ist ja gut
Man übertreibt es halt nicht
LP
UTF8 String
A Pointer to UTF8 Encoder String
Okay das klingt
Das klingt schonmal ganz gut
Way to dank
Auch keine Memory
Okay das muss man wissen
Das muss man echt wissen
Das
Das es ein automatisches Free macht
Weiß nicht nach was ich suchen muss
Das ist interessant
Also
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet
Guck kein
Memory Leak
Das muss man in dem Fall wirklich wissen
Weil damit rechnet man eigentlich nicht
Gut also hätten wir den Part ich muss sagen
Das ging einfacher als gedacht
Jetzt benchmarken wir das ganze mal
So auf die schnelle
Wir können danach noch ein ordentliches
Benchmark dot net Projekt drum rum machen
Um das beides zu vergleichen
Aber
Probieren wir das mal aus
Übrigens das da
Auch PPGar
Das hier soll eigentlich die Funktion sein
Die nichts returnt
Und Go Call 2 soll die Funktion sein
Die was returnt
Sonst wird das nix
Jetzt müssen wir das hier anlegen
Interop
Kopieren wir das mal Call Go 2
Und Call Go ist einfach nur Void
Okay
Jetzt benchmarken wir das ganze mal
Ganz kurz
Auf die Schnelle also
Stop Watch
Start
Okay aus irgendwelchen Stunden
Alter aus irgendwelchen Gründen funzt mein
Console Rightline Makro nicht
Elapsed
Total
30 Seconds
Stop Watch Stop
Und hier darunter hier dazwischen rufen wir mal auf
Interop
So das hier sollte so gering sein
Ein einfacher Function Call das das gar nicht auffällt
Im Endeffekt ja
Das ist jetzt weil er zum ersten mal aufgerufen wird
Da wird ja nix drauf geben
Wir machen da mal ne Schleife drum
So machen wir mal
100 Aufrufe davon
Und gucken wie schnell das ist
Und einmal rufen wir es vor der Stop Watch auf
Damit es nicht mitgezählt wird
Wo bist du überrascht das es Pointer gibt
Okay ja das ist sehr schnell jetzt
Gibt es in C Sharp auch
Einen Typ für String Pointer
Ähm in
In C Sharp sind Strings immer Pointer
String ist ein
Raph Type
In C Sharp ist ein String unter der Haube immer ein Pointer
Ohne das du explizit
Was hinschreibst
In C Sharp ist eigentlich 90% der Sachen
Die du verwendest Pointer
Ohne Pointer Syntax
Ich glaube er meint aber über der
Was wie jetzt
Achso ne das ist jetzt in dem Falle
Von Interop mit wirklich
Raw C Pointer
Zu Managed String Objekten
Damit geht er echt nicht so um wie erwartet
Ja das
Als dumm gibts das nur wenn ich anscheinend
Nicht explizit sage
Was ich vermute was hier passiert
Sobald ich hier hinschreibe
String dann checkt er
Wenn das ein
Oder
Dann erwartet er einen Character Pointer
Kopiert sich
Den bis zu einem Null
Terminator in einen .NET String
Und macht dann einen Free auf den ursprünglichen
Pointer
Das ist Ultra Magic unter der Haube
Was da passiert
Und wenn du das nicht haben willst
Dann musst du einfach sagen mach kein String draus
Sondern nimm den Raw Pointer
Und dann kannst du den selbst auslesen und freen
Das muss ich echt sagen
Wenn du das in dumm haben willst
Okay dann was du machen kannst ist
Ach das meinst du
Du kannst auch sowas machen
Das funktioniert auch
Unsafe Character Pointer
Moment
Haha
Nein das ist nicht das gleiche
Du musst einen Byte Pointer
Pointer auf Start von einem Byte Array setzen
Weil
Das ist auch ein bisschen Verarschung
Da müssten wir aufpassen
Wenn man einen Character Pointer macht
In C Sharp ist das nicht das gleiche
Wie ein Character Pointer in C
Und ein Byte ist in C das gleiche
In C Sharp ist ein Character 2 Byte
Weil
C Sharp Strings intern als UTF 16 speichert
Deswegen ist quasi
In C
In C ist das da
Quasi mehr oder weniger
Das gleiche wie das da
Und das da auch in C Sharp
Aber in C Sharp ist Character Pointer was anderes
Also das könntest du auch machen
Das geht allerdings nur mit Unsafe davor
Weil sobald du Pointer Magic machst
Sagt C Sharp
Könnt auch in die Hose gehen
Aber muss man in dem Fall gar nicht
Weil tatsächlich die Managed Implementierung
Von diesem
Also unter der Haube machen die schon das richtige
In dem einen Fall
Ja
Umwandeln, kopieren in den .NET String
Und da unten drunter Free Callen
Das ist schon sehr Magic mäßig
Ne ne das ist egal
Unter der Haube ist das alles das gleiche
Die Interpretation
Der Daten ist dann ein bisschen anders
Zum Beispiel das du bei einem
Byte
Kein Minus drinstehen haben kannst
Aber bei einem S Byte
Bei einem signed Byte
Aber das ist reine Interpretationsfrage
Es ist alles in C
Ein Byte
Egal ob es ein Character ein Byte
Ne ein Short ist 16 glaube ich
Ist ein Short nicht in C 2 Byte
Also
1 bis 16.000 noch etwas
Da bin ich mir jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht sicher
So
Aber jetzt haben wir uns
Jetzt haben wir uns etwas
Side Tracken lassen
Anscheinend ist .NET mittlerweile so
Five Head schlau
Das ist wenn man so komische Dinger
Macht wie ich
Von denen ich nicht geahnt hätte
Dass sie funktionieren
Tatsächlich funktioniert
Ohne Memory Leaks zu verursachen
Das hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht
Ok
Jetzt wollte ich das mal ganz kurz Benchmarken
Wie schnell ist denn das ganze
Ok ein paar Nanosekunden
Aber 100 ist ja auch nichts
Machen wir mal 1000
Oder machen wir mal eine Million
Es gibt übrigens ein nice Feature
Von Seiten Passy Sharp Version
Kennt ihr das hier
Das man Underscores in die Zahlen machen kann
Die eigentlich nichts ändern da dran
Aber viel viel besser lesbar sind
Ja jetzt erkennt jeder das hier
Dass das hier
Das ist eine Million
Also das ist quasi 10 Millionen
Machen wir das mal weg
Dass das eine Million ist
Das kann man viel besser lesen
Man darf übrigens nicht auf die Idee kommen
So zu versuchen
Weil dann ist das ein Float
Beziehungsweise ein Double
Also mit 2 Punkten geht es dann auch gar nicht
Aber das hier ist nice
Das andere wären 10 Millionen gewesen
Es ist kein Unterschied
Aber man kann es auch so schreiben
Das ist ein bisschen pepega
Aber es würde auch funktionieren
Oder so oder so
Aber das macht eigentlich keiner
Also das finde ich ganz nice
Dass einfach Underscores in Zahlen ignoriert werden
So eine Million Aufrufe
Oh das ist schon recht langsam
90 Millisekunden
Für eine Million Function Aufrufe
Ist das ein Callback Function
Zu einer Go Funktion
Das ist kein Callback
Wir haben eine Funktion in Go
Und zwar der hier
Guck
Wir haben eine leere Funktion in Go
Die einfach nur Call Go heißt
Die in die Library reinkompiliert wird
Die Library wird in .NET
Geladen
Definiert dass es darin eine Funktion
Call Go gibt
Und dann wird die aufgerufen
Unter welchen Umständen merkt man das
Naja ganz ehrlich
Eine Million Function Calls
Sind schon ganz schön viel
Nicht wirklich merken
Es sei denn
Man hat wirklich irgendwie so
Irgendeinen Parser oder so
Wo das millionenfach aufgerufen wird
Pro Durchgang
Dann macht es schon Performance
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal den Unterschied
Wir machen jetzt mal eine
Static
Public
Nennen wir es mal
Call
.NET
Nennen wir das jetzt mal
Also das ist jetzt eine .NET Funktion
Mix irgendwie über Library
Ist eine ganz normale .NET Funktion
Ist das
Und wenn ich die jetzt mal aufrufe hier
Call.NET
Dann werden wir sehen
Bam 1,2 Millisekunden
Und mit Release Modus
Wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen weniger
Ja
Also 500
Nanosekunden
Versus
500 Nanosekunden
80 Millisekunden
Ok also
Cinterop ist immer noch nicht das
Allerschnellste was man machen kann
Das ist echt lahm
Das ist wirklich lahm
80 Millisekunden für eine Million
Funktionsaufrufe
Also von .NET nach .NET
Braucht das ganze
500 Nanosekunden
Also hier 0,5 Millisekunden
Und
Von .NET nach Go
80 Millisekunden
In normalen Anwendungen wo das nicht oft aufgerufen wird
Ist das überhaupt gar kein Problem
Ja
Aber so
Ist schon ordentlich
Overhead
Ich mein selbst bei meiner WebRTC Anwendung
Wenn man 30 FPS
Hat pro Kamera
Und 100 Kameras drin dann sind das 3000
3000 Function Calls
Pro
Sekunde
Ist halt nix im Endeffekt
Nix
Das ist egal ob ich Function
Ob ich hier C Go Overhead habe
Das juckt einfach nicht
Für jeden Function Call einen neuen Thread starten
Ist vielleicht ein bisschen Overkill
Aber das würde
Zumindest teilweise die ganze Sache
Schneller machen
Also besser parallel
Also es ist schon
Ja
Schon ein bisschen langsamer
Ich glaube in dem Fall macht .NET gar nicht
Magie sondern es ist eher Go was die Magie macht
.NET macht in dem Fall
Ein relativ straight
Call wie man halt eine C Funktion
Callt bisschen Magic
Bestimmt aber Go macht halt extrem
Viel Magic für ihren Thread
Und Runtime Scheduler
Das sich das nicht in die Quere kommt
Also C Go ist
Berüchtigt oder Go ist berüchtigt dafür
Das der Interop mit anderen Sprachen
Echt langsam ist
Du hast Recht du hast Recht
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt mal
Im Debug Modus
Du hast Recht
Also im Debug Modus brauchen wir ungefähr
82 Millisekunden 85 Millisekunden
Go und Call .NET
Brauchen wir
Eine Millisekunde
Ja du hast Recht
Das könnte durchaus sein
Das die Sharp schlau genug ist
Und die Funktion rausschmeißt im Release Modus
Weil es feststellt okay
Das ist eine Schleife mit nichts drin
Also scheiß drauf mach weg
Test mit einem Print
Print ist immer ganz ganz mies
Print ist auf die Konsole
Und Single Output und so
Ne der überspringt
Ich habs jetzt im Debug Modus
Da wird nichts geskippt
Der ruft die wirklich auf
Aber ganz ehrlich
Das ist auch zu erwarten
Das ein Function Call von .NET
Nach .NET nahezu kein Overhead hat
Wäre ja auch schlimm wenn nicht
Okay also
Dann haben wir das jetzt ausprobiert für Go
Wollen wir mal gucken wie schnell
Das mit dem Struct ist
Oh das ist natürlich noch mal
Eine ganze Ecke langsamer
Haha
Ja es schwankt ein bisschen
Wir machen gleich mal
Wir machen gleich mal ein Benchmark
Komm wir machen jetzt schon ein Benchmark draus
Wir machen jetzt schon ein Benchmark draus
Bevor wir die Rust Sache basteln
Nougat
Benchmark
.NET
Bam
.ăn
. маш
.NET
Wie geht, Moment, Moment, wie ging das jetzt nochmal, Moment, Moment, irgendwie Benchmark, Runner, ne, ne, ne, Benchmark, Runner, Runner, Benchmark, Runner, Run, Benchmark, okay, das hier oben kommt weg, das, ein Aufruf hier oben ist okay,
okay, das kommt da rein, Public, Void, das nennen wir jetzt einfach mal irgendwie Run, Run, Go oder so, dann kommt das hier rein, machen wir, machen wir aber mal nur, nur, ja doch, na komm, 1000, 1000 Aufrufe ist vielleicht besser, da kann das mehrfach, mehrfach die Funktion aufrufen, okay, Go, Run, äh, und jetzt, ich glaube, jetzt muss man hier noch Benchmark drüber schreiben, ne, okay,
so, und jetzt sollte der in Ordnung sein,
dass wir eine ordentliche Ausgabe haben, wie schnell der ist, zack, wow, what, there are not any result runs, warum, failed, der erkennt wieder mein .NET nicht, man, was ist das für ein Abfuck, okay, Export, hier, Path, Export, .NET, kann man hier drinnen, kann man hier drinnen relative Fade verwenden, gar nicht sicher, .NET,
version, minus, minus, version, 7, ne, also, Home, Max, jetzt ist es 8, okay, mach doch in die Bash RC, eigentlich will ich meine System.NET Version nicht überschreiben, so, und jetzt sagen wir Run Release, jetzt soll es hoffentlich gehen, ja, jetzt wird ordentlich gebenchmarked, fast wie in einem Nick Chapsas Video hier,
da wird auch immer, 50 mal, falls dir jemand guckt, da wird auch immer bis zum Umkippen gebenchmarked, wenn du eine Variable für die Anzahl machst, kannst du die Anzahl der Durchläufe testen, so, also, Go hat im Durchschnitt 182 Mikrosekunden,
also für 1000 Aufrufe,
und das ist jetzt halt nicht, nicht so schnell, äh, warum, warum, ich brauch ja keine Parameter, oder, hast du dir mal das Video angeguckt, da muss ich nicht das Video angucken, das hab ich oft genug erzählt, dass die .NET Versionierung beschissen ist,
da hab ich ja schon, hab ich ja schon selbst oft genug gesagt, also, ach, komm, machen wir einfach, machen wir nur 100, komm, so, und wir callen jetzt das ohne Overhead, also das, das nix macht,
so, und jetzt das Ganze nochmal für Rust, auf geht's, Krustentiere versammeln, ah, ja, ja, danke schön für den Sub, Bolgi19, huge Subscription,
sorry, falls ich irgendjemanden übersehen hab, ich guck mal kurz rein, Creator Dashboard, der Karlsson, danke für den Sub, hab ich den Zappcon,
Schifter, und Stripes, der Razer hat auch Subscribed vorhin noch, der Alfred auch, gar nicht richtig gesehen alles hier,
so, also, es wird Zeit für Go, wir kommentieren das hier gerade mal aus, und ich sag jetzt mal, call, wir brauchen jetzt, wir brauchen jetzt, call, call Rust,
das wird nicht funktionieren, weil es das auch nicht gibt, ja, bam, Crash, gibt es nicht, so, also, ich muss jetzt in Rust eine Library erzeugen, die Rustlib heißt,
jetzt geht's los, ich hab keine Ahnung, wirklich absolut keinen blassen Schimmer, wie ich das jetzt machen soll, okay, also, müssen wir, müssen wir mal suchen, Rust, ähm, FFI,
The Rustonomicon, okay, jetzt kriegen wir, jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt, also, Calling Foreign Functions,
ah, oh, Rust ist so eklig, Alter, wenn ich das hier schon sehe, ich dreh, dreh aber, Crate Type, äh, wie, wie macht man das überhaupt, da gab's doch mal irgendein GitHub, Rust FFI Examples,
guck mal mal, hat er denn, C Sharp to Rust, das ist doch schon mal ein gutes Beispiel, ja, Cargo Tommel, also, das braucht man,
Lip, okay, also, let's go, wir müssen in unsere Cargo Tommel gehen, und da jetzt ein Lip hinzufügen, Lip, äh, Name ist einfach, äh, Rustlib,
oh, Rustlib, so, wahrscheinlich wie der Output heißen soll, CD Lip klingt gut, und jetzt ist die Frage, wie funzt das Source, Lipass, ja, Copy-Pasten wir uns mal hier rein,
und nennen es Call Rust, aber wir haben kein Input und wir haben kein Output erstmal, no Mängel, extern, FN, Call Rust, okay, das hier bedeutet, glaube ich, dass er die Namen genauso lässt, wie die Funktion heißt, sodass sie später aufgerufen werden kann,
und Main können wir eigentlich rausmachen, no Main Function found, ja, ist doch klar, will ich auch nicht mehr,
okay, Source, Main, in Lip.js, achso, Cargo Run geht natürlich, Cargo Build, ohne Fehler hat es gebildet, ich weiß es nicht,
hm, und jetzt, wo ist das Ganze, Target, Debug, Lip, Lip, Rust, Lip, hört sich ein bisschen kacke vielleicht an, oder, wie habe ich es genannt,
einfach nur Rust Lip genannt, also, dann heißt es hier einfach nur Rust, Build, Lip, Rust.so, ja, meinetwegen, dann heißt es halt nicht Rust Lip, sondern Lip Rust, auch gut, kann ich auch mitleben, okay,
und jetzt Build, okay, Minus, Minus, Release, wobei eigentlich wurscht es, wie ich das nenne, wir können auch sagen, Build Release, dann sagen wir CP, oder MV, ähm, Target, Build,
Release, Lip, Rust.so, hoch zu, ähm, Benchmark, und dann soll das einfach heißen, Rust Lip.so, ich benenne es einfach um, doch, doch, das ist eigentlich schon richtig, ich habe es nur falschrum benannt,
ich habe es falschrum benannt, Lip, das ist auf jeden Fall, so, so ist richtiger als meins, mit Lip zuerst, okay, so, jetzt haben wir in unserem .NET Projekt noch eine Rust Lip, die fügen wir hinzu in den Output,
dass er die auch findet, wenn er dann später, später läuft, ja, so, also, Build Action, äh, Copy, hier, zack, so, und wenn wir Glück haben, funktioniert das jetzt schon,
hey, es läuft, Rasteraufruf, Funst, so, Beweis, Moment, Beweis, dass es funktioniert, Source, äh, Print, was, Module, Declaration, Reload, immer, Restart, hilft immer,
okay, nice, so, jetzt bringen wir mal, das, Brindeln, Keg W, Build, und jetzt Aufrufen von .NET aus, Moment, oh, zu viele Fenster, Aufrufen von .NET auf, Keg W, nice, Funst, sehr gut, exzellent,
okay, jetzt können wir mal testen, wie schnell das ist, in Godas, in, in, in, in Rust das Ganze zu machen, und danach bauen wir das noch mit Rust und Struct zurückgeben, also, wir sagen jetzt Interopt,
Call, Go, und zwar mein Benchmark, Interopt, Call, Net, wir machen jetzt alle drei Sachen, so, also, wir kopieren uns den Benchmark, und den Benchmark, sagen wir Run, Go, Run, Rust, und Run, Run.NET, das sollte ja eigentlich das schnellste sein, Call, Net, und hier, Rust, jetzt bin ich mal auf die Ergebnisse gespannt, was da rauskommt,
C, Release, wir machen es auch so schnell wie geht, zack, lassen wir das mal kurz laufen, und ich gucke in den Chat, Moin, bin aktuell auf Windows, ich würde gerne auf Linux rüber wechseln, OS gefällt mir sehr, jedoch zweifle ich noch, dass ich, da ich gerne zocke, und ich weiß, wie gut das unter Linux funktioniert, ganz ehrlich, wenn du viel spielst, und je nachdem, was du spielst, wenn du Spiele beispielsweise mit Anti-Cheat spielst, also, wobei, CS ja wohl mittlerweile ganz gut funktioniert, aber wenn du sowas wie, sagen wir mal, Rainbow Six, Fortnite, und so, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das
oder sowas spielst, dann hast du eigentlich verloren unter Linux.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, mach das so wie ich erstmal, benutze Windows als Host, und auf dem zweiten Windows-Desktop eine Linux-VRM im Fullscreen, wo du zwischendrin hin und her schalten kannst, du machst in der Linux-VRM alles, was du machen willst, was gut unter Linux ist,
und für Sachen wie Videos gucken, streamen, Videobearbeitung, irgendwelche Games,
dann machst du es unter Windows.
Da hast du, finde ich, das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Und das Gute ist, du kannst dich ein bisschen an Linux gewöhnen,
ohne dass du irgendwie Dualboot machen musst oder direkt ins kalte Wasser geworfen wirst.
Also zum Anfang einfach nur eine VM und gut ist.
Und so, was sagt denn meine Benchmarks hier?
Meine Benchmarks benchmarken noch.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was rauskommt.
Also ich meine, eigentlich kann ich es mir schon denken.
.NET am schnellsten, gefolgt von Rust und dann Go hintendran.
Also in diesem einen speziellen Fall jetzt.
Was macht der da eigentlich so lang?
So, ja.
Guck mal, boah.
Alter, was ein Unterschied, Mann.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Okay, also unser Benchmark ist 100 Funktionsaufrufe, die nichts machen.
Ja, also von einem Funktionsaufruf 100, nicht einer.
100 Funktionsaufrufe von .NET nach .NET sind natürlich abfackschnell.
28,8 für Nanosekunden.
Das ist megaschnell, ja.
Das ist aber auch klar.
Gefolgt von Rust.
Call in Rust.
Also die haben einen super, super...
C-Interface, was einfach funktioniert, ohne viel Overhead.
Nur 125 Nanosekunden für 100 Aufrufe.
Das ist auch im Prinzip nix, eigentlich.
Und jetzt kommt Go.
Go braucht einfach mal, sehe ich das richtig, 8 Millisekunden.
Also 8.114 Nanosekunden.
Jetzt muss ich ein Video machen auf YouTube, dass Go stirbt, ja.
Placingly fast.
Rust is destroying Go.
Ähm.
Go will be dead soon.
Oder irgendwas in der...
Wir brauchen noch ein bisschen mehr Klick...
Ne, wir brauchen...
Wir brauchen Clickbait.
Go is dead.
Here is why.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Äh, Mikrosekunden.
Jaja, Mikrosekunden.
Wir sind hier in Bananosekunden.
How Go-Lang is destroying your performance.
Genau.
Mikrosekunden, nicht Millisekunden.
Ja, ich hab mich vertan.
Kann man auch mal durcheinander kommen.
Also, .NET, logischerweise in dem Fall das schnellste.
28 Nanosekunden.
Rust, 125 Nanosekunden.
Würde ich sagen, das ist so wirklich...
Da kannst du ohne Probleme nach Rust callen.
Und hier 8 Mikrosekunden.
Nicht, dass 8 Mikrosekunden schnell wäre, aber es ist um Größenordnungen langsamer als Rust.
.NET steht ja eigentlich gar nicht zur Auswahl, weil die WebRTC-Libraries für .NET...
Es gibt Zip-Sourcery für .NET, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Aber ich finde...
Ich finde, dem fehlen noch ein paar Features, dass man sie komplett so gut benutzen kann, wie die Go-Library zum Beispiel.
Und die Rust-Library weiß ich noch nicht.
Das ist ein Nachbau von der Go-Library, die ich verwenden will, aber ich weiß nicht, wie Feature-Complete die schon ist.
Macht die Übung mal anders, von Rust als Base und Import C-Sharp.
Also, von Rust nach Go wird mehr oder weniger genauso sein.
Aber von Rust nach C-Sharp ist gar nicht so einfach möglich.
Weil C-Sharp braucht eine .NET-Runtime, die läuft.
Das heißt, ich müsste quasi eine .NET-Runtime in Rust hosten.
Was sicherlich geht.
Ja, du kannst AOT machen, aber ich erzähle euch, wie es die ganze Zeit gewesen ist.
Du brauchst quasi...
Du musst quasi eine .NET-Runtime in Rust hosten.
Ich glaube, das will man nicht machen.
Seit den letzten...
Seit .NET 6, aber eher seit .NET 7 und noch spannender wird es mit .NET 8.
.NET 8 kommt ja demnächst raus.
Da unterstützen die ja auch Ahead-of-Time-Compilation.
Also im Prinzip das, was so ein Compiler macht.
Normalerweise halt irgendwas Native-Ausführbares rauswerfen.
Dann kann man auch...
Moment, da gibt es wirklich was.
Da kann man dann auch direkt Funktionen draus aufrufen.
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes.
Das ist Rust zu IR kompilieren, was dann in .NET laufen kann.
Das ist auch Sixhead.
Das ist sowas gibt.
Aber das ist andersrum.
Also ist Rust in .NET.
Wir wollen ja .NET von echtem Rust aufrufen.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber nochmal...
Was ist IR Intermediate?
Also das ist quasi IL.
IL und IR ist das...
Ist das...
Ist das gleiche quasi.
Hä, bin ich jetzt blöd?
So hier.
Ja, IR.
Also IR und IL ist das gleiche.
Im Endeffekt.
Das ist nicht direkt ausführbar von deinem Rechner,
aber ausführbar von der .NET Runtime.
Also C-Sharp kompiliert ja auch nicht direkt in ein Binary,
was du ausführen kannst,
sondern C-Sharp kompiliert in Bytecode,
den .NET ausführen kann.
Und wenn du in den C-Sharp Binary startest,
dann ist es in Wirklichkeit so,
dass erstmal .NET gestartet wird
und .NET startet dann deine C-Sharp...
liest dann das CLRIR und so weiter.
Oder IL ein.
Je nachdem wie man es nennt und führt das aus.
Und dort ist es so,
dass quasi Rust zu IL umgewandelt wird
und IL kann dann von der .NET Runtime ausgeführt werden.
Das ist halt echt schon richtig Sixthead.
Ich wüsste nicht genau wozu das...
Ich meine, ja um Rust Libraries in C-Sharp zu verwenden.
Aber es funktioniert noch nicht alles.
Aber cool, dass das funktioniert.
So, jetzt haben wir unser Benchmarker.
Das Benchmarkzeug hier am Start.
Das werde ich jetzt gerade einfach mal wieder auskommentieren.
Und wir gucken uns mal an,
wie man in Rust ein Struct baut
und das Struct zurückgibt an C-Sharp.
Also Call Rust 2 brauchen wir jetzt noch.
So, das legen wir jetzt hier auch mal an.
Ich prophezeie, dass es etwas einfacher wird als in Go,
weil Rust C-Interop ist ziemlich gut in der Regel.
Aber Rust hat schon .NET Libraries, oder nicht?
Nee.
Rust ist Rust und Rust ist nicht .NET normalerweise.
Hast du einen coolen, vielleicht auch leichten Weg mit Rust?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich glaube, man muss ganz schön masochistisch sein,
veranlagt sein, mit Rust Windows UI Anwendungen bauen zu wollen.
Das ist einfach nur so mein Bauchgefühl dazu.
Ja, nice.
Blazingly fast written in Rust.
Muss jetzt aber auch bei allen anderen Anwendungen, die ich hier habe,
bei allen anderen Anwendungen, die ich hier habe,
bei allen anderen Projekten dabei schreiben.
Also, okay.
Wie macht man, es geht ja schon mal los, Leute,
wie man überhaupt einen Struct in Rust macht.
Struct.
Okay, so schön.
Nice, Max, super.
Ich glaube, so weit wären wir wahrscheinlich auch schon gekommen, oder?
Okay, aber wie geht es weiter?
Rust, Struct.
FFI, suchen wir mal danach.
Complex Data Tabs and Rust FFI.
Genau, okay, also, Inamstruct, hier, Rebr, Rebr, Rebr, C, okay, das ist so ein, das ist so ein typisches Rust-Ding, das können wir Copy-Pasten, das ist eines der Gründe, warum Rust echt nicht schön zu lesen ist, Pup, Pup, ist quasi was wie Public, Public Ausschreiben ist outdated, overrated, also machen wir hier mal das gleiche, Session, Name, okay, wir fangen einfach an, wir machen wieder das gleiche,
ähm, hier, Client-ID und, ne, komm, wir sind, wir sind, A, B heißt es jetzt, so, Uint, ne, Moment, Int, Moment, es ist Rust, da ist es U64 einfach nur, gell, ja, es ist Rust und hier nochmal, hier noch ein Bool oder so, ja, okay, Build, es bildet noch und jetzt Return,
tja, das ist eine gute Frage, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das, so, A, 1, 2, 3, B, Moment, B, True, ne, das ist ein B-Kolon vielleicht, hä, Juch, äh, so, hm, was hat er denn für Schmerzen,
oh, weil ich keinen Return-Type angegeben hab, ähm, Rust-Return-Type ist so, gell, ja, okay, ist schon besser, schon besser, übrigens, ich hab's verkackt, ich hab's in der falschen Funktion gemacht, das muss hier unten rein, Format, okay, und das funktioniert jetzt, Moment, das funzt, okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das, wie das zurückkommt in, in .NET, wir brauchen, wir müssen das mal kurz ein bisschen ändern, hier, Session, Rename,
Session, äh, Go, Session, Rust, so, Uint, und dann haben wir hier einen Bool, und, ja, A, B, wie's heißt, ist egal, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das, das ist ja die Basics, das sind einfach nur Values zurückgeben, und, unser Ziel ist ja hier auch noch einen String zurückzugeben und sowas, das wird dann schon noch ein bisschen komplizierter, Call Rust 2 zurück, bekommen wir eine Session, okay, Call Rust 2,
Session, gleich, Session, A, und, Session, B, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das funzt, was da rauskommt, 1, 2, 3, und True, True, 0, W, ja, das funzt, okay, das, das war schon ein bisschen einfacher als in Go, an der Stelle, weil Rust ist deutlich besser, also, wir brauchen kein C, Go, und C, Struct definieren, und sowas,
das ist einfacher, so, und jetzt kommt ein String, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das funzt, kann ich, kann ich einfach sagen, String, das geht doch im Leben nicht, oder, wenn ich hier einfach sage, ich return einen String, oh, keck, weh, okay, jetzt kommt Rust gedöhnt,
jetzt, warum kann ich einem Struct String keinen String zuweisen, weil man irgendwie sagen muss, pass as String, oder sowas, ich erinnere mich dunkel,
from String, from, to String, wo ist der Unterschied dazwischen, aber das habe ich schon mal, das habe ich schon mal gesehen in Rust, ja, das kompiliert zwar, aber das wird nicht funktionieren, das wird, das wird so nicht funktionieren, weil die Rust String Repräsentation ganz anders ist, als das, was sich C Sharp vorstellt, aber wir können es mal ausprobieren, wir stellen, wir stellen uns einfach mal wieder doof, und sagen, das ist ein String,
okay, so, das wird nicht funzen, nein, es crasht sogar, crasht es, crasht es wirklich, ja, es crasht, okay, es crasht, es crasht komplett, macht einfach gar nichts, also, das funzt so definitiv nicht, aber das habe ich auch schon gedacht, ich brauche, ich brauche einen C, C String, oder sowas, oder einen, oder einen Character Array, oder sowas,
wir gucken mal eine Hilfe von Rust, ach hier, guck mal, Const C, Const C Char, hat er importiert, Const C, das geht natürlich nicht, kann man sowas wie, kann man sowas machen wie Pointer, S Pointer, aber das, das ist kein nullterminierter String, das, das, das, äh, kann man sagen wie Into Pointer, oder so, weil so Rust, Rust Magic,
das funzt nicht, ne, da sagt, was ist Const, okay, Const U8, das ist jetzt ja quasi ein Byte Array, kompiliert, es kompiliert, ich bin mal, ich bin mal gespannt, was jetzt in C Sharp rauskommt, es crasht einfach wieder, okay, es, es crasht, okay, dann probieren wir mal was anderes, dann probieren wir mal was anderes, Int Pointer, Int Pointer, das sollte jetzt nicht mal crashen,
es crasht immer noch, was, Double, ich hab die Go Session bearbeitet, ah, ich bin ein Kack Noob, okay, das funzt, also hier gibt's, hier gibt's den Int Pointer, hier, hier krieg ich den Int Pointer zurück, und was kann ich mit dem Int Pointer jetzt machen, sicherlich nicht als String parsen, oder, Marshall, Pointer, to String,
Bam, geht nicht, Pointer, to String, ey, das funzt nicht, das ergibt aber auch Sinn, dass das nicht funktioniert, weil Rust Strings sind ja nicht Null Terminated, und, und sonst wie das, das, das, das klappt nicht, jetzt haben wir noch Mut, Mut U8, haben wir auch noch, nicht, dass das was ändert, oder so, ups, ne, ne, das funzt nicht, okay, also, ich muss da irgendwie mit C String hantieren,
C String, New, A, B, C, Unwrap, das klingt,
sehr Rust Style, machen wir's mal sowas hier, Let Str gleich, C String, was, New, und jetzt hier sowas wie, Kek W, oder so, ja, und an der Stelle dann, hier machen wir auch wieder Cha, C Cha, und an der Stelle dann Str, okay, ne, funzt nicht, warum,
Expected Const C Cha,
Found, Result, ah, nochmal Unwrap, hä, Unwrap, äh, Unwrap muss da oben hin, Unwrap, was, Unwrap into Raw, what, into Raw, S Pointer, klingt doch, klingt doch sinnvoll, oder, S Pointer, zack, kompiliert, Run, oh, das lookt nicht korrekt,
das lookt gar nicht korrekt,
das sieht nach, wurde gefreed aus,
das ergibt auch Sinn, dass das nicht funktioniert, weil, Rust,
wird das hier wahrscheinlich verwerfen, sobald die Funktion zu Ende ist,
jetzt ist die große Preisfrage,
wie krieg ich Rust dazu, dass es das,
dass es überlebt,
wir gucken uns mal die Hilfe von C String in Rust an,
ja, Global Definition,
Global Definition,
nee, nee, nee, nee,
Extracting a Raw Pointer,
Äste, was,
S Pointer,
also eins kann man Rust ja meistens nicht vorwerfen,
lassen zu wenig Docks haben,
aber, dass ich nicht durchblicke,
ist schon wieder,
S Pointer, ja, so schlau bin ich auch,
Safety,
ähm,
ich muss, ich muss dem Ding jetzt,
also, bei Rust ist es so,
Rust ist super pingelig,
was Lifetime von Objekten angeht,
und Rust ist schlau genug und weiß,
am Ende dieses Dings,
normalerweise müsste ich jetzt sowas machen,
ja, irgendwie und,
also Rust Logik, da muss man dann und Mut oder so komisches Zeug da vormachen,
aber das,
also, da, da, da, dass ich Rust sage,
ich möchte,
quasi,
das Ownership, heißt das bei Rust, übertragen, an den der aufruft,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert,
geht mit nem Apostroph, mit,
was,
so,
alter, Rust macht mich fertig,
ne, ne, das kann's nicht sein, oder,
Examples,
den hatten wir schon,
S Point,
from, weg,
wenn du willst, übergibst du einfach noch den C-String nochmal als Feldinstrukt,
ich übergebe doch den, das Feldinstrukt,
hier,
oder, oder du meinst hier C-String,
ja, aber das wird doch da nicht so funktionieren, wie ich mir das gedacht habe, oder,
so,
ne, ist not FFI safe,
das, das wird nicht funktionieren, so,
siehste,
crasht einfach direkt, ne, ne, ne, ne,
so, so funzt das nicht,
ähm,
wir, wir, wir sind, glaub ich, auf'm richtigen Weg,
das ist, das ist, glaub ich, gar nicht so verkehrt,
vielleicht muss ich einfach sagen, Mut,
hier oben, anstatt Const,
in C-Sharp muss das in den Session-Daten zu String geändert werden,
ne, muss es nicht,
ich bekomm den In-Pointer,
und den wandle ich dann selbst in den String um, das muss auch funktionieren,
ok, das geht nicht, warum, weil,
Type differs in,
Expected Raw Pointer, Mut, Found Raw Pointer, Const,
brauchst exter-, Alter,
jetzt kommt richtig krasses, nices Backseating hier an den Start,
so, und das, und das soll jetzt funktionieren,
da hab ich so meine Zweifel, dass das funzt,
Chatge, und,
funzt nicht,
bam,
ich will dem sagen, dass das, dass er hier Ownership übertragen soll,
ok, wie, wie geht das,
was haben wir denn sonst noch hier,
From Raw,
Into Raw,
Consumes the C-String and transfer Ownership of the String to the C-Caller,
das ist das,
was ich wahrscheinlich will,
Into,
Into Raw,
das gibt ein Mut-C-Char,
ja, was ja auch durchaus ok ist, ich kann ja da drin rumsauen, wie ich will, mach ich aber nicht, aber könnte ich,
ok, lässt sich kompilieren, und jetzt, und jetzt,
Pause Champ, Leute, Pause Champ,
Pause Champ,
ich, ich finde meine Emotes grad nicht,
Pause Champ, Time,
Funzt,
Easy,
kaum macht man's richtig,
Easy as fuck,
Easy,
hat funktioniert,
also, so funzt das in Rust,
C-String,
äh, Moment, und dann, und dann sagt man,
Moment, das ist Go,
Null,
äh, und dann sagt man,
Into Raw,
so, was haben wir denn sonst noch,
The Pointer, which this function returns,
must be returned to Rust,
must,
and reconstituted using,
C-String from Raw,
oh jetzt, das wär auch zu einfach gewesen,
das wär auch zu einfach gewesen, wenn das jetzt schon fertig ist,
passt mal auf, jetzt haben wir Memory Leaks, oder?
Jetzt haben wir Memory Leaks as fuck wieder,
Sekunde, while,
true,
passt auf, jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir wieder richtig Memory,
Ultramemory, Memory Leaks haben wir jetzt.
Oh, ho, ho, ho,
Alter, der hat sich in 3 Sekunden,
vier gigabyte ram geschnappt monke ist vier sekunden zwei sekunden vier gigabyte ram weg
das ist schon kein memory league mehr was kommt was kommt nach was kommt nach einem league das
liegt davon liegt zu sprechen ist eindeutig schon viel zu wenig das ist das ist das ist kein league
da ist einfach schon nichts mehr nichts mehr offen da gibt es noch nicht mal einen damm dazwischen
das ist einfach da ist einfach nichts dazwischen das ist alles alles das ist schon ein see quasi
ohne was dazwischen 22 sekunden vier gigabyte ram mich würde nicht wundern wenn irgendeine idee
abgekackt ist jetzt weil er zu viel ram sich geschnappt hat halbe forkbombe ist das schon
ohne sich zu folgen gut also was muss man was muss man machen the point which is fun must be
return to rust and krieg konnte using c-string
from raw to be properly deallocated da bin ich mal gespannt ob das stimmt was die da sagen wir
machen jetzt da einfach mal ein string draus weil dann wissen wir ja dass der automatisch fried und
jetzt sollten wir kein memory league mehr haben wir haben kein memory league mehr alles perfectly
fine na oder vielleicht doch so ein kleines memory league vielleicht wir haben kein memory league aber
auch ein kleines genau die sharp macht wieder free profile ist doch ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gerade
nicht wie gescheit weil mein rider ist irgendwie der meinung debugger funktioniert nicht warum auch
immer vielleicht jeder jetzt obwohl es mit dort versucht man jedoch netz location ergibt überhaupt
keinen sinn da sollen meinen dort nett verwenden und nicht das falsche dort nicht der ist es nicht
nicht. Das Ganze ist ein .NET 8
Projekt und er zeigt es auch hier an, dass es
.NET 8 ist, aber Ryder
ist der Meinung, nee,
ist es nicht. Guck hier, .NET 8, .NET
Version 8. Ich
weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Er gibt
keinen Sinn. Ich glaube, fast
das ist ein Bug in Ryder, was wir hier haben.
.Memory.
So, und jetzt lesen wir mal weiter, was
hier steht.
Ja, okay, hier.
Specifically
one should not
use the standard
C free function to
deallocate the string. Das ist schon
mal falsch, was wir da gerade machen.
Failure to call
C string
from raw will lead to a memory leak.
The C side must not modify the
length of the string. Ja, okay.
Also müssen wir noch das hier machen.
Bedeutet im Endeffekt auch,
so dass wir kein Memory
leaken, brauche ich noch eine Funktion,
die nennen, ups,
brauche ich noch eine Funktion,
die nennen wir jetzt einfach mal hier
free str
oder so.
Und da rufen wir jetzt auf
C string
from raw, okay, hier
Pointer rein.
Und dann wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich, okay,
rust, rust, geht das so?
Achso, das muss in den unsave Block.
Ist ja fast wie in .NET hier.
Bäh.
Ich will das so haben.
Warum, warum sieht der unsave Block
hier so kacke aus? Ah, dann machen wir es so.
Okay, und jetzt ist das, jetzt ist
das safe.
Da muss ich das aber noch dazu aufrufen.
Und zwar
würde ich
sagen,
muss ich dann hier noch
was reinpacken.
Und zwar, nicht
call rust, sondern
free str
int Pointer.
Äh.
So, und wenn ich jetzt das MemoryLeague
vermeiden will, sage
ich interop
free str
und gebe da session
meinen
ne, nein, ich meine string, das
funktioniert ja so jetzt nicht. Ja, okay, jetzt
ergibt das den, jetzt müssen wir es nämlich wirklich
selbst machen. Int Pointer,
ich hab schon wieder das falsche
editiert, Mann. Ich hab schon wieder die
Go session editiert, ja.
Int Pointer, wir benennen das
übrigens mal gescheit, sonst kann ich's
gar nicht mehr nicht merken.
ClientName, so.
Und jetzt sollte das MemoryLeague
auch wieder weg sein.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Da liegt nix mehr.
Ich meine, es ist
offensichtlich, vorher hatten wir vier
Gigabyte pro, pro zwei
Sekunden und jetzt haben wir nix.
Okay. DotMemory
hab ich noch nie ausprobiert. Kann man DotMemory
vielleicht installieren über die Toolbox?
Dot.
Trace haben wir. Dotnet
Dotnet Performance
Profiler.
Geht das damit auch?
Hab ich noch nie, hab ich noch nie
verwendet.
Zeigt der mir, zeigt der mir auch
die Memory Usage?
Eigentlich, ohne Scheiß,
eigentlich fuckt's mich jubelst ab, dass der, dass der
Rider Debugger nicht geht.
Warum geht der Rider? Okay, ich hab ne Idee, woran
das liegt. Wir gehen jetzt mal hier auf
Build and Toolsets.
Es ist automatisch, es ist,
eindeutig richtig eingestellt.
Kann ich das, kann ich das
systemweit speichern einfach?
Und jetzt funzt's?
Shit. Warum benutzt
der? Alter, was ist das für ein Kack?
Warum benutzt der so ein olles, so ein
olles outdatedes Dotnet?
Versteh ich nicht.
Es ist irgendein Bug.
Hier ist alles richtig eingestellt.
Ne, ne, der Rider
benutzt
die Runtime, die ich ja ausgewählt hab normalerweise.
Aber anscheinend macht's das in dem Fall
nicht, weil's irgendwie verbuggt ist.
Was ziemlich
suckt? Ich weiß es nicht.
Das sind doch die richtigen Settings, oder was?
Ich wüsste nicht, was hier dran...
Weil die Runtime
auch stimmt. Wir können hier nochmal die
Runtime hinzufügen.
MaxHome.net
Dotnet.
Custom. So, Apply.
Ah, jetzt geht's!
Jetzt geht's. Glaub ich zumindest.
Oder? Ja.
Memory.
Nicht so was? Chatgear.
Ich benutze den Debugger in Rider sehr selten.
Haben die nicht so
eine Anzeige wie in Visual Studio Code, wo man
einfach sehen kann, live, was das für
Memory verwendet? Anscheinend
nicht, oder? Ja, stimmt auch wieder.
Aber es war blöd, dass das nicht
eingebaut ist, oder? Das ist dann tatsächlich
eine Sache, wo ich sagen würde,
da ist Visual Studio Code
angenehmer. Äh, nicht Visual Studio Code,
Visual Studio angenehmer.
Auf die drei Dots bei Debuggen.
Um eins hier, oder wo?
Da, da. Profile with Sampling.
Ah.
Excellent.
So, und wo sehe ich jetzt den,
den RAM-Verbrauch? Erst, wenn ich's
wieder geschlossen hab, oder
sehe ich das live?
Da gibt's noch eins für Memory. Echt?
Snapshot?
Ey, das ist aber nicht die Memory-Size, oder?
Boah, da blick ich nicht durch. Das ist mir
zu high IQ jetzt.
Das ist mir massified.
Zu high IQ. Was ist jetzt
CPU? Ja, ich hätte gerne Memory.
Das massified IQ Zeug hier.
Hier stoppen wir mal.
Profile with? Profile running
Process? Profile...
Sampling? Memory!
Ja, sowas
suche ich. Genau.
Excellent.
Genau das habe ich gesucht.
Dass man sieht, wie viel Speicher
das Ding verbraucht. Man sieht,
wir haben absolut null
Memory-Leaks. Gar nix.
Null Memory-Leaks.
Das ist einfach die ganze Zeit
immer auf 43,59.
So, wir
können das Ganze nochmal
checken, indem wir
sagen...
Wir lassen das Free mal weg, aber
wir machen...
Wir machen mal nen Sleep kurz rein
von
einer Millisekunde,
dass es...
Jetzt hatten wir's mehrfach gelaufen.
Dass es nicht sich komplett in die
in die Quere kommt,
ja. So, und jetzt sagen wir
Profile with Memory.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet...
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass
das irgendwie...
Es geht hoch! Ja, es geht hoch.
Guckt, Leute. Es geht hoch.
Langsam, weil ne Millisekunde
Sleep dazwischen... Und ne Millisekunde
ist verdammt viel, wenn der Millionen
Aufrufe pro Sekunde macht normalerweise.
Ja. Jetzt sieht man,
dass ein Memory-Leak drin ist. Guckt, es geht immer ein bisschen.
weiter hoch. Nice, nice.
Okay, heute... Das ist
wirklich nice, dass ihr
wusstet, wo das ist, weil...
Ähm...
Wir können aber sagen, Timespan
from
Microseconds
Jede Microsekunde
einfach... Bam.
Profile Memory. Oh ja,
guckt, Leute. Jetzt geht's
steil. Jetzt geht's steil.
Die Speichern aus Gigabyte.
1,2 Gigabyte.
1,4, 1,6, 1,7.
Ja, jetzt wird Memory-Leaked as fuck.
Jetzt hat man's...
Jetzt hat man's wirklich gut gesehen.
So, und jetzt machen wir das free rein.
Jetzt machen wir das free rein. Aber Chat,
da habt ihr mal was Gutes gezeigt.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt.
Das ist mega praktisch dafür.
Rider ist einfach echt beste.
So, guckt. Und jetzt
kein Memory-Leak mehr. Es bleibt einfach mal
44 MB Memory total used.
Excellent, Leute.
Excellent, excellent.
Okay.
So, und was lernen wir daraus?
Okay, wir machen jetzt nochmal einen abschließenden...
Wie kriege ich denn das hier minimiert?
So, jetzt machen wir nochmal einen abschließenden Vergleich zu diesem ganzen Cample.
Wir schmeißen das hier raus.
Wir sagen...
Das da wird einmal aufgerufen.
Dann wird
interop
call
rust einmal aufgerufen.
interop call
rust 2
und
call go. So, jetzt lassen wir uns einmal noch
Benchmark-Ergebnisse generaten.
Zum Vergleich.
Das kommt weg. Also, den .NET
Vergleich, den machen wir mal wieder raus. Den braucht
eigentlich niemand an der Stelle. Wir wissen,
dass .NET schnell ist. Von .NET
zu .NET. Ja, also hier run.
Gucken wir uns das nochmal abschließend
an. Go 2.
Und
run rust
rust 2. Wobei
da tatsächlich
noch einen free machen müssen.
Der in go unter der Haube passiert.
Aber das ist ja nicht
schlimm. So.
Und jetzt können wir nochmal den Benchmark laufen
lassen. Und uns
freuen, dass wir eine tolle Benchmark-
Ausgabe kriegen.
Glaube ich zumindest, dass ich nichts falsch
gemacht habe. Oh, doch.
Run, run
rust.
Fehlt noch das normale
Call, rust.
So. Okay.
Wenn man jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte, wäre perfekt.
Gibt es überhaupt go 2, ja?
Gibt es? Go 2 macht
das mit dem struct.
So. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Absoluter high-IQ-Stream, Leute.
Ja, stimmt schon. Übrigens schön, dass so
viele Leute wieder am Start sind. Ich meine,
das ist ja nicht selbstverständlich, dass
quasi die ganze Zeit über 200
Leute zugucken bei so einem Kram
hier, ja. Muss man beim
struct in rust nicht auch die
Namen anpassen? Oder hattest du das schon
gemacht?
Nee, warum brauche ich die Namen anpassen?
Was meinst du? Du meinst, weil das in
C-Sharp heißt
session rust und session go?
Das ist wurscht.
Wichtig ist einfach
nur, dass die, das Speicherlayout
das gleiche ist. Ich könnte es auch
kequate, qchat,
ayaya nennen, das struct.
Vollkommen egal, wie das in C-Sharp heißt.
Client ID ist der Name
auch egal. Der Typ ist das wichtige.
Also Hauptsache, dass das
struct das richtige Memory
Also, dass es in Rust A und B heißt, ist
vollkommen egal.
Wichtig ist, dass es ein struct ist,
dass als erstes ein bool kommt, als zweites
ein int, als drittes ein string oder sowas.
Das muss stimmen in beiden Sprachen.
Wie das heißt, ist vollkommen egal.
Weil
die Namen stehen da nirgendswo drinnen.
Was der sich einfach merkt, ist
die size von dem struct
und wie er das dann quasi
casten muss in den eigentlichen
Managetyp
von der Speicheraufteilung her.
Ja, ich mag die Streams auch.
Ich meine, ich kann natürlich nicht immer
so Sachen aus dem Ärmel schütteln.
Immer nur, wenn was ansteht.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was bei den Benchmarks rauskommt.
Wobei, eigentlich bin ich nicht gespannt.
Wir wissen alle, was rauskommt.
Rust schneller.
Um Längen schneller.
Guckt mal.
Die Funktion, hier,
die pure Rust Funktion aufrufen
ist einfach
124 Nanosekunden zu
8,5 Mikrosekunden.
Und
hier ist, Go braucht
für die Geschichten mit dem struct
18 Nanosekunden
18.000 Nanosekunden
Ne, ne Moment.
18.000 Nanosekunden, also 18
Millisekunden, sehe ich das richtig?
Chat? Ne, Mikrosekunden.
Mikrosekunden, nicht Millisekunden. Meine Güte!
Boah!
Einheiten!
18 Mikrosekunden und
Rust braucht einfach nur 2.
Ist schon ne ganze Ecke
schneller. Und hier
haben wir, und das dürfen wir nicht vergessen,
hier haben wir 2 Calls
drinne.
Wir haben, und es sind trotzdem
schneller, wir haben 2 Calls.
Wir haben den
eigentlichen Call zum
struct erzeugen und
wir haben den Call zum Free noch
drinne.
Nimm mal String als Type und nicht Pointer, lass ihn Free
Callen, sollt schneller sein. Ne.
Also ja, vielleicht
ist das ein Ticken schneller,
weil .NET das Free macht und nicht
Rust gecallt wird, aber
die Rust Docs sagen
explizit, man soll nicht
Free Callen, sondern soll das
zurück an Rust geben und Rust soll es
Freeen.
Sonst Memory Leak.
Es ist, also du hast Recht, das ist schnell, aber wir
können das ausprobieren.
Schade nix, wir können das ausprobieren.
Ich lass das, ich lass das mal weg.
Und wir ändern den hier zu String.
Wir haben ja gesehen, wir haben auch nahezu kein Memory Leak
und führen das ganze nochmal.
Ja.
Jetzt sollte er schneller sein, aber wir haben
potenziell ein Memory Leak. Zumindest
sagen die Rusts,
sagt die Rust Doku das, dass
wir dann einen Memory Leak haben.
Wenn wir das nicht so machen.
Also Arduino
plus Rust habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich bin eher der
ESP32 Enjoyer
und da ist Rust ja auch
nur, sagen wir mal so, sehr rudimentär.
Vieles geht ja dem Rust noch nicht. Ich glaube Rust und
Wifi geht glaube ich auch noch nicht
auf dem ESP32.
Genau, das
genau deshalb denke ich auch.
Es kann ja auch möglich sein,
dass Rust nicht einfach
das Memory
allocated über
das normale C Maloc,
sondern irgendwas eigenes macht.
Da bringt ja normales C Free an der Stelle
ja auch wenig, wenn da noch Sachen
nestet, irgendwie anderweitig allockiert sind,
von denen nur Rust was weiß.
Also das ergibt schon Sinn.
Und dass das auch ein Memory Leak hat,
gehe ich auch von aus, aber es dürften
wahrscheinlich nur ein paar Bytes sein.
Über Unsafe sollte WLAN gehen.
Sofern man die
eingebauten
ESP C Sachen aufrufen kann
aus Rust, dann vielleicht, ja.
Aber ehrlich gesagt muss ich sagen,
Plattform IO
und auch wenn da unter der Haube
C++ für ein ESP32 ist, ist
recht angenehm.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass in dem Fall C++
und ich sag's nur ungern, ja,
aber C++ für solche Sachen angenehmer ist.
Rust plus Arduino, gibt's
da denn ein gutes Projekt für?
Wir hatten das geschrieben.
Gibt's da ein gutes Projekt für?
Kannst mal schicken, vielleicht können wir uns das wirklich angucken.
So.
Leute, ich weiß nicht
warum, aber das Ganze ist jetzt langsamer geworden.
Wenn wir C Sharp
freeen lassen. Okay?
Also es ist schneller,
es ist schneller Rust freeen zu lassen
als, als
C Sharp freeen zu lassen.
Okay.
Ah ja.
Meinetwegen, soll mir recht sein.
Okay. Der Benchmark
hier unten ist aber für meine Sachen
eh nicht sonderlich relevant,
weil die Funktion, die ich wirklich schnell
in der Schleife aufrufe, ist nicht
was Strings oder so returnt,
sondern das returnt gar nichts.
Bekommt einfach nur einen
Pointer als Parameter übergeben,
den es auch nicht selbst freeen muss.
Also insofern ist das hier
eigentlich für mich der relevantere
Benchmark. Und da ist Rust
meilenweit schneller. .NET ist noch
einen Ticken schneller, also .NET zu
.NET ist logischerweise schneller als .NET
zu Rust, aber Rust ist um
Welten schneller als Go.
Überrascht mich
aber auch nicht, weil ich wusste, dass C Go
langsam ist und ich wollte einfach mal gucken,
ob es
mittlerweile besser geworden ist.
Ich würde sagen, es ist besser geworden, aber
es ist immer noch ziemlich lahm,
wenn man millionenfach das aufruft.
Wenn man das jetzt einfach nur ein paar tausend Mal
aufruft oder so, pff, drauf geschissen,
dann macht es ein bisschen Overhead auch nicht aus.
Aber wenn man das millionenfach pro Sekunde aufruft,
dann macht es schon einiges aus.
Was ich übrigens auch nicht machen werde.
Also.
Jetzt könnte ich auch einfach
die Go Library verwenden.
Aber warum? Ich meine,
wir können, das machen wir dann in einem
der nächsten Streams, da machen wir dann
WebRTC in Rust.
Sind auch Aufrufe von
Go nach C langsam?
Ja, ja, auch.
Theoretisch sind die einen Ticken schneller.
Also früher war es so, Aufrufe von
Go nach C waren langsam.
Also auch
langsamer als von anderen Sprachen.
Von anderer Sprache nach C.
Aber
in Go rein callen
von C aus, war noch mal
eine Ecke langsamer.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile ist es glaube ich
ungefähr gleich langsam.
Aber das ist auch langsam.
Es ist vielleicht nicht ganz so langsam
wie von anderer Sprache zu Go.
Aber auch langsam.
Go hat mit,
mit den langsamsten Interop
mit anderen Sprachen
von allen Programmiersprachen, die es gibt.
Go an sich ist relativ flott.
Aber sobald du quasi aus
Go raus musst oder rein musst
in Go von anderen Sprachen,
was ja alles immer über irgendein C-Interface
geht, da ist Go richtig langsam.
Was auch ein Problem ist,
weil die ganzen
Wrapper-Libraries für SQLite
oder für irgendwelche anderen
Low-Level-Sachen, die sind
potenziell in Go einfach arschlangsam.
Weil
C-Go langsam ist.
Also wenn man ordentlich Load drauf hat.
Deswegen gibt es beispielsweise
für SQLite
ein Projekt, das SQLite
transpilt
nach Go,
damit es native Go
kompiliert werden kann und nicht
mit C-Function-Calls.
Weil SQLite unter
ordentlich Last wohl
eine nicht zu unterschätzende
Overhead hat, weil es sehr viele
C-Calls macht in Go.
Weil SQLite halt eine C-Library ist.
Ja.
Also macht Probleme.
Go ist schnell, solange man sich
innerhalb von Go bewegt.
Und gibt es noch ein paar Examples?
Examples?
Plattform-IO. Nice.
Haben die das jetzt offiziell in
Plattform-IO drinne?
Ne, das ist das ganz normale
ESP-IDF.
Source. Main-AS.
Ok, ja, da haben sie Wrapper um Sachen
gebaut. Ok. Ja, also anscheinend
kann man...
Also anscheinend kann man auch
das programmieren. Aber ganz im Ernst, das
tu ich mir dann an.
Ja. Nice Chat.
Fast 3 Stunden. Heute ganz schön lang
gestreamt worden. Morgen 3 Stunden, jetzt 3 Stunden.
Ist Moris Video.
Ja. Chat.
Wir sind fertig für heute.
Schön, dass ihr am
Start wart.
Guckt mal kurz, ob wir irgendjemand
hosten können.
Ich hoffe euch hat der Stream heute gefallen.
Wir haben... Ok.
Hier haben wir einen am Start.
Vielleicht hoste ich den. Zeigt mal.
Der macht...
Jaja, Fake E-Mail.
Der macht Defop plus
Kubernetes.
Oh. Der...
Ich glaube der macht auch gerade seinen Stream aus,
weil er eben Stream Manager ist.
Na gut. Dann nicht.
Ok. Chat.
Dann gehe ich auf. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you. Winke, winke.